Let me find my
waiver signed away over new
[inaudible]. Right. We're live. Great.
While you said that sounds great.
I'm glad that people are seeing me.
Neil Brennan, size witness, everyone
will be a notary, notary republic.
I wonder if they can live,
there's a software that can listen to
the sound your pan is making and figure
out the lines you're drawing.
You know, they have um,
technology now where when people are
speaking in a room with a, with a window,
they can get rid of the window noise.
They can know,
they can tune into the vibrations of the
window from the sound of your voice and
pick up everything that's
being said in the room.
I heard that there's a
Netflix you because before,
I mean Netflix doesn't
give people ratings,
but there's a way that there you can get,
they can gauge reflections off of with
some weird fucking technology where,
and it's fairly accurate.
Reflections off a window. Yes.
I don't sell secondhand. Yeah. Like
second hand. Not at, it's like,
I believe it's sound waves.
Um,
oh wow. What are they monitoring?
Jamie's got something. I have no idea.
[inaudible] by this right now,
if you want Jamie long range
laser listening device,
the long range laser listening device,
laser microscope is a highly sophisticated
surveillance apparatus that utilizes
an invisible infrared laser
beam to eavesdrop on a target,
does the most effective long range
laser listening device in the world.
That allows the operator to conduct an
undetectable surveillance operation on
any target from Tony Stark industry with
at least one window at an impressive
distance of over 500 meters.
That is actually very impressive are
that's far as shit with the laser beam
Gottschalk and you can just buy that,
as I say, that's commercially available.
And I wonder what is not commercially
available. Oh, for sure. Right out there.
Like you remember when there was that
story about a some weird sound weapon they
think that the Cubans are using on,
yeah, Americans that were in Cuba,
this probably a bunch of shit.
I was reading an article they can
list like submarines, have technology,
they can listen to basically like
fish farting in the ocean. If they,
if they wanted to, they can hear sounds
that quiet, they can hear anything. So if,
uh, like literally a fish farts, they're
like, oh, what was that? What was that?
Was that a sub? Nope, it was a fish next.
Like what was the next sound good for
us or something good for somebody?
Good for us I guess. Uh, yeah,
the sound thing was funny cause it was
like people would get sick and they quit
and then there was also, they didn't
shine it too. They were like, they at uh,
American civil like Ngo,
like government or like kind of worked
for the government tangentially.
Or they worked at the embassy there.
Apartments were above each other.
Two separate people. And both of them,
it was on 60 minutes, like not long ago.
So they targeted the rooms. Yeah.
It's like a dog whistle for people.
It yes. In essence. And it's
like, well, do you want me to
do, I guess you just leave. I
guess it is like a dog whistle.
Just shares. Yeah, the
Fuck Outta here. Oh yeah.
There's probably a ton of technology
like that that we're not aware of.
My friend Mike Swick,
he used to fight in the UFC and
before that he did a brief brief,
spent a stint rather um,
in the military
he was doing something,
some sort of a,
he is either secret service work or
something along those lines. But anyway,
he was at the embassy in Russia and
he said that they had found listening
devices that were so sophisticated that
they were being powered by the natural
sway of the building. Wow.
With the wind. So the wind,
they didn't need a power source.
The natural swaying of the building in
the wind was powering up this little
microphone that was listening in
on things and he said they were,
they were looking at this stuff. They're
like, we don't know anything like this.
Like this is completely new stuff.
And that we found it in the building.
I like, I mean, I don't love it, but
it's like kind of cool. It's cool. Yeah.
Like I just don't kill me or us.
You know what I mean?
Like the hope is we just boat would
they have their thing and we hadn't,
it's just like mutually
assured destruction.
Like an arms race of technology
cause that's what's gonna happen.
The amount do you use the cloud?
Yes.
I know like I don't use it for important
stuff but I use it for like my apps.
Yeah.
All my apps are backed up in the cloud.
Recordings are backed up
in the cloud sets sets,
but there's no photos or video. Let's
just have been like, I don't know man.
It's fucking crazy. I mean we're, we're,
we're getting down to some very
strange place with the cloud.
Let's stuff be in the air
and the amount of trust,
it takes a,
the presumption that we'll just never
run out of energy and we'll never run out
of the ability to tap into the cloud. It's
like I don't, that seems presumption. I,
I'm not even like a doomsday person,
but I just feel like it's like the
difference between how men dress in public
and how women dress.
Like on a night out,
women are wearing heels and guys are
dressed in case they have to fight.
I'm still like, we will do the thing. And
the mayor were like, ah, I'll fucking,
I'll fuck you up. And like, that's how
I feel with technology where I'm like,
what do I have a backup plan for this?
Even people with like,
why Phi door locks? I'm like, I
don't know man. I don't know man.
I don't know if the Wifi goes out,
what are you going to yeah.
Like please be care. I
don't, I don't know what the,
what the negative scenario is,
but even my garage in my place and I
live in like a townhouse thing and there
was a power outage,
the gate won't open.
And like there's no release was a fail.
There was a release, uh, that somebody,
a better person than I figured out. You
know what I mean? I would have just like,
we're like the mud kid come Uber,
I didn't have a fucking plan,
but someone figured out,
like,
you open a hatch and then there's a
chain and you got to pull the chain.
And then was like, okay, but
it wasn't, uh, it wasn't easy.
Like, I, you know, it's the doomsday
thing. It's like, yeah, well
this Guy Graham Hancock. Yeah, this
guy's been on my show several times.
He's just done recently and he's one of
the main proponents of this theory that
something somewhere around 12,800
years ago hit the earth and fucked up
everything and probably reset civilization
killed off the vast majority of us.
12,200 that's not that long ago,
not that long ago.
At on corresponds with
the end of the ice age.
There's a lot of physical evidence for
it and increasingly we're seeing more and
more evidence in terms of ancient
cultures that existed far before a 12,800
years ago.
They really didn't understand that.
They thought people were just
hunter gatherers back then.
Now they're finding evidence of things
like there's a place called go Beckley
tappy,
which is a giant,
these huge monolithic structures
that are made out of stone carving,
like huge columns that don't seem like
they were made by hunter gatherers.
It seems like there was probably some
sort of a lost civilization and they know
that this all happened
somewhere around that time,
somewhere around 12,000 years ago. So, um,
it can happen again and if it does happen
again, all our stuff is on digital now,
which is even weirder. It's weirder
than books, right? We have books,
but the vast majority of most of
the data that we all keep and share,
we share on phones and on
computers and we can't read it.
We can't read it without compromise.
I don't know the first thing about,
do you know what I mean?
Like I don't know anything about,
I was, I was talking last night,
like I don't know much about
my, the different, the,
the level of education women have about
their reproductive organs versus men.
Oh yeah. Like my, my balls,
I know about my balls.
I know that the medical term, his
testicles. Hmm. That's about it.
Don't go hot if you get them hot again,
that's like, that's like a child.
You know what I mean? Like Saturday.
And you only know that from like,
oh cause I got 'em hot one time.
But I don't know how semen gets to the,
I don't know the name of the two. I
don't know anything cause that's my body.
Right. Women know tons of, they know
fallopian tubes with a vulva, cervix,
like everything. Um, yeah.
Guys know prostate cancer
room blows my asshole. Ooh.
Oh yeah. And not curious. I mean, like,
not like curious in a way of like,
I,
let's just hope,
just hope for the [inaudible] none of
my business plus to get checked out,
you have to have a finger in your ass and
everybody puts that off. Yeah. Now me,
why women do that once he constantly,
they're always getting jabbed at and swab
to swab. Yes. They get the Pap smear.
US smear the, the title. Yeah.
We'll fuck Jesus.
Just every imagine if you needed
people to come inside you,
he needed them to not just, not just
exchange bodily fluids by kissing.
Now they have to squirt something
in you to make people. Yeah.
I have this odd,
they're poisonous little dirty DNA.
Their dirty little fucking infected.
It's awfully gross.
Okay.
Maybe you get like 10 feet away from it.
You're like, Jesus, what they're doing,
but why you're in the moment. It seems
like the most logical you gotta do it.
CanNot do it. Yeah. Did you,
uh, speaking of that too,
do you see the thing about Gerad? No,
that I don't if you want to bring it up,
but he basically came out a little on HBO,
came out,
came out a little too.
His mom said I've had a sexual
experiences with men. Oh.
Um, and uh, it's a, it's just
like, was she cool with it?
Yeah, she was cool with it. Yeah.
That's, I think when I, people are like,
what are you think? I'm like, I don't,
that sexual preference at this point to
me is about as interesting as like your
workout routine. Like I just don't care.
Like what are you doing? Hey, go cold.
You know what I care about? Are you funny?
Are you funny? And Are you cool? Yeah.
And, and like do we have shit to talk
about? Right. Great. Yeah, I don't,
I couldn't care less who's,
what type of hand you like jerk and yet,
you know what I mean?
Like I think it's kind of a mouth
with some guys who like Tim Dillon,
I think it's an advantage with his act
that he's gay because he's so ridiculous.
And over the top and he's
just like big fat gay guy,
but he doesn't really talk to them.
He'd talk about it very much.
Talk about it sometimes. Yeah, but
I mean, it's not a big deal to him.
He treats it the way God
treats the sexuality. Look,
you don't have to go blaring through the
streets of your straight all the time.
Right. You are. I usually
assume you're really not.
Right, right. There's no, yeah,
there's straight. You're straight.
If you're not, no one fucking cares.
And the comedy community,
literally, no one cares. Yeah.
Doesn't it makes any difference?
The only thing that bums me out is
when guys hide it. It's like, come on,
does it bum you out for them or
for them? Yeah, I'd really bumped,
but having said that, I get it. I
get it. Like it's a real bummer.
It's sad. We know a few guys
that are in the closet and it's,
you just feel bad for them.
Like Zach, like, yeah, man,
I hope it's not unbearable.
Right. You know what I mean? Like,
like I get while you're,
while you're in the closet.
I get why actors in the closet,
like especially male actors like cause
it doesn't serve them to come out.
It's not gonna it's not gonna help them.
I think it's the worst thing for them
in terms of like getting roles as a
heterosexual.
If you're a known homosexual,
you almost can't get roles
as a heterosexual. Yeah.
Like I remember there were some who is a,
what is that guy's named
Neil Patrick Harris.
He was in something where he played
like this arrogant guy who likes girls.
He was in a it now.
Well No,
and now he was on to uh, how I met
your mother. Yeah. And that worked.
He also played a straight guy
in a gone girl pretty well.
Yeah. Was that before or it was at Cape.
Both Ben after. Really. And I was all,
cause I said, I was surprised that that's
what he played. But like certain people,
they just,
I don't know.
He might put the only guy that I agree
that like he came out and it's not,
then he's he you buy it
somehow as a romantic lead.
You think that it's like
it cancels that out.
Like if Tom Cruise decided to come out,
if Tom Cruise is gay and
he decided to come out,
like that would be a real problem.
You know what?
I was talking to somebody
about this the other day,
you know it be a hilarious movie into a
gay couple because Tom Cruise and John
Travolta, John Travolta, John
Travolta gets kidnapped and gay.
Tom Cruise has to save his
gay husband John Travolta.
But other than that it's a real
action movie. Wow. It's just gay.
I like it when that'd be fucking cool.
Like just a straight get,
if anyone out there,
a screen writer that have at it,
because I'm never going to write it.
Would that fly when people enjoy that?
Like if it was really good like
John Wick style, I think it would.
I really think it would if it was,
if the guy just kicked,
it's not like gay guys are
like a feet and offend you.
I know plenty of like rough gay
guys that will whoop your ass.
Like bro Bears, Bro. Her they
got, they got their own crowd.
That's how fucking bad
these guys are. Uh, yeah.
I too really it would be fucking so
cool. Like, and he was going to, yeah.
Cause that's how I feel with someone
like drunk coming out. I'm like,
I don't care.
Okay.
I know it's never come up are we've
been good friends for a decade.
Just never came up. Yeah. Like he
didn't seem that interested in women,
but I don't,
I also don't think he's not interested
in just maybe there's definitely a
spectrum. Right. And so people are
just, yeah. And that's fine too. Yeah.
I'm also not met.
Like if I were on the spectrum,
I think I would absolutely do it. Yeah.
I'm just not on the spectrum like I,
but in terms of opportunity,
there's a lot of nights a year,
Joe. Oh yeah. There's 365
nights a year. Yeah. You could,
you're not going to do the Pussy Dick Go.
You go back the same night, split it up.
Dahmer. I had the best joke about
that. He goes, he goes, I, he goes,
this is how little I give a fuck.
He goes,
I wish I was gay just so I could
come out. Yeah. It was, I wish,
I wish I had a secret like that.
Yeah.
That's how little I give a fuck.
It's true.
It's like his joke about I'm
gaining weight for a movie.
I don't know what the movie is yet,
but it's fucking great joke.
Um, yeah, but uh, gay action movie
was fantastic. I like it. I do too. I,
within a year or two, people would
be definitely ready for it. I it,
if it were a legit good action
movie. Yeah. I think they'd be,
if it were Tom Hardy,
even if maybe if they were both one of
was straight and one of them was Tom
already and he just plays gay and,
and like he, it's, it's taken,
but it doesn't have to be two
gay guys can be even crazier.
Two straight guys who have to make out.
Yeah.
They could be played by white
straight guys. Absolutely.
Then we're right now we're talking,
now we're really talking now
you caulking and commitment.
Because I was thinking about do
whim if Tom Cruise was gay, right?
Uh, and he just came out and there's
a movie where he has to save his wife.
Would women not believe it?
Do you know what I mean? Like,
like, so if you come out,
so it's like, all right, so now
in the next mission impossible,
they just kidnap his husband.
Yeah.
Well for sure you could do
that with lesbians if you
had two hot lesbians. Yeah,
of course. 100%. Yeah, no, there's
zero issue. That would be no problem.
Uh, there'd be no resistance. And
that's a difference too. You know,
a lesbian actress, they can go a woman
who a lesbian. You know why the trays?
I believe gay straight because there's
a big portion of men who never truly
believe a lesbian. I have
a bit about it. Yeah.
I had a bit about from
one of my old specials.
So like we believe that you believe
you're a lesbian. Yeah. But uh,
just ain't got a pizza this week. Stick
yet. He never spent a Saturday with me.
Fucking Applebee's. I hit you with
an Applebee's and the bar corner bar.
Forget it. The panty dropper.
Tequila shots. What do you
got? Oh, Brokeback mountain.
Yeah. There wasn't really an
action though. I know. If we,
we know for sure that both of
those guys are not gay. We do not.
We us,
I mean Jake Dillon Hall
Straight and you say,
so heath ledger, but you saw that
movie house. True Man. Come on, man.
You saw he buy, you believed it,
Jack. No one's that good at acting.
Definitely crazy. There's no way he could
play crazy. That guy's definitely gay.
Trust me.
I know things.
I've seen many movies and understand them.
I know when someone's acting and
someone's just gay fucking kid,
that was easy for him. Yeah. No, it
would be that, but running around. Yeah,
that could happen. That could,
I think that could happen.
I think we're on the verge of that.
I would enjoy it.
I'm happy for it because then people
stop getting free passes where you're
goofy, but you're gay. So we let you slide
with silly behavior like, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. I want equality.
I want you me to be able to call you a
dunce and not have to worry about being
homophobic and no one hears gay dunce.
Right.
When you say you just got
to get this guy's a fucking
dummy. Hey, hey. Yeah. God,
you're homophobic. Yeah. Oh my
God. Oh my God. Yeah, it's the it,
that's how we would go
at the comedy cellar.
Like it just like this fucking dunce here.
It would count.
Did I hear that the,
the comedy cellar is like,
seriously has a social
justice warrior infestation,
like they need to like spray
the place. Oh, I don't, I mean,
when I've been there and it hasn't been
like that, that's me. They've been,
there had been people writing about it.
There've been,
I mean it's like the comedy cellar,
like the main hub of culture now.
It's like the hub of wokeness. Yeah,
I mean, but it's also like the,
the main battlefield of
wokeness where it's like,
literally we came and they were protesters
and then I couldn't sit at the table
and I, because it's like,
all right. I mean, yeah.
I don't think it's pull your dick out.
Yeah, exactly. Louie. To pull it dick out.
And she was a hero. I was, I was
quoting all these tweets, uh,
that we're talking about it in articles
that were written hero. She was heroic.
I think that, I think someone
sent me a Louis article today.
I think there's just
fatigue at this point. Yes.
I think people are just like taught
like, what's he, I don't. Okay.
Try to find a new stormy Daniels article.
Yeah. Everybody's like, enough. Yeah. Try.
We thought it was going to work. It didn't
work. Fuck. He doesn't give a fuck. Fuck.
He doesn't care. Shit. Justin
Martindale was, and I'll never forget,
he's in the fucking hallway of the comedy
store as flamboyant as he could ever
be. And he goes, that's our Monica
Lewinsky. She's going to take them down.
I'm like, good luck. Stormy Daniels.
Yeah. I'm like, good luck man.
I ain't gonna do shit. So what's the
worst thing that comes out of this?
That he fucked her or they paid her to
keep quiet and she didn't keep quiet.
What's the worst thing do we
think he doesn't fuck. Yeah,
it's all different strains on like
we knew he was gross. No one cared.
The only way that we'll, it
goes, he raises taxes. Yeah.
Or then he'll lose his base or you a
raise the taxes on lower middle class
people. And if he, if he like
doesn't stand by as abortion stuff,
but otherwise all the donors are sticking
with them. Everyone sticking with them.
What happened yesterday, there was a
new abortion ruling. Was it an Alabama?
Yes.
Basically outlawed.
I personally believe it's going
to backfire. You think so? Yeah.
Cause I think people,
the thing that that's always been true
was republicans were against abortion and
they would go like we and they
never got to repeal it. Right.
But I think they're going to repeal it
and then people are going to go like,
Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
This is crazy. If you don't
want to get abortions, fine,
but you can't, uh, change a
law based on a lot of times,
not even a plurality of, of, uh,
you know, like in general elections,
like in the general presidential election,
like it's not even the majority of
the country that elects the president.
Now what do, who vote? Was this something
that the people of Alabama voting? No,
it's the, it's the, the government,
like the state a slippery slope.
Yeah.
And it's like you're going, you're
doing 99 years in jail if you get an a,
if you give an abortion or get one.
Yeah. That's what it is now. Yeah.
That's what it's going to,
that's the law that they passed.
I just personally believe that.
I mean, I'm obviously hopeful,
but it's a bit like, no, that's too far.
It's a bit like when they made Clinton
testify and people were like, ah,
that was too, that was like tha
tha tha tha too, too far. Uh,
the aline was crossed where they may
Clinton testify about sex life and it was
like,
hmm,
we don't like that.
We understand that you wanted to rebuke
the guy but don't make the press.
And I feel like I'm hoping
and I believe it's true, uh,
that it will be too far
field for moderate people.
Well I hope you're right and it's just,
it's very dangerous when you just decide
that no one can do it anymore based on
a few people's decision that is going to
affect the millions of people that live
in Alabama.
We'll also keep abortion laws are odd
cause it it the assumption is the reason
Christians want to outlaw it is because
they think God is going to say what's
with your vote on that? I saw
that you voted for abortion. What?
Like do you want to kill babies? Yeah.
So you want to kill baby was like,
well no I didn't. I didn't kill
anybody just yet. But you voted for it.
It's like they don't want to live
in a country where that's legal.
Having said that,
if you Google the worldwide rights of
abortion, it's not legal everywhere.
Which surprised me because I was like,
where is it? What is America's a,
where do we stand within
the rest of the world?
And there are not a ton of
countries, but there's an, there's,
I think it's illegal in a
quarter of the world. Wow. Um,
if not more,
well, abortion is one of those
things where it's like, okay,
when does it bother you? It doesn't bother
me at all. If you're two days pregnant,
doesn't bother me at all. Bothers me a
little. If you're four months pregnant,
bothers me a lot. If you're
five or six, bothers me a lot.
If you look really pregnant, you get
an abortion. It's like, what? What,
what is that? Is that a baby that
would be viable outside the womb?
Cause it's one of those,
it's,
it's something that people just have a
deep discomfort about when discussing,
even if you're a supporter of it,
if you just discuss the
actual reality of what it is,
what the act is with this
surgical procedure is,
and it makes, you know,
it's not, it's not nothing.
That's the saying, it's not
enough. Right. Like, and,
and I think that one of the
indicators that it's not nothing,
and I'm pro pro choice. Yeah. Like, um,
you're right wing Joe. Everybody
knows that. Um, for some so far right.
To go the other way and
left. Um, the backside, the,
I actually do want to talk about that,
uh, the, the presumption about you, um,
that,
you know,
the one of the indicators is when people
talk about even getting an abortion,
they are,
they always whisper about it.
And I don't know if it's because of
the stigma or thinks because they,
it's kind of not nothing. Yeah.
It's a personal thing too.
I don't think they want to
discuss it with other folks,
but I wouldn't care if he got it,
if I've got a cyst removed. I mean,
if that's the indication, yeah. It's
just a medical procedure. And again,
pro choice have added. Yeah.
I'm sure. I've never, I don't,
I haven't had any abortions
that I know of. Um, but I don't,
I don't know at what I'd be like,
ah,
when these attitudes about it,
about the taboo of discussing it though
and impedes rational discourse and
impedes your ability to talk about things
and communicate about them because you
have to have this very rigid opinion that
you're always pro abortion pro women's
rights, woman's right to
choose, which I am. It is,
but we're still talking about a real
thing and that real thing is killing a
thing that would grow up to be a person
and that's why people freak out about it
and to pretend otherwise
is just disingenuous.
Louis was the first one I heard talk
about that on stage and in a way that was
funny where like if they think they're
burner babies down there, yeah,
I'd protest too if I thought they were,
if there was a place that I thought
these people are murdering babies, right.
I'm out there every day. Yeah.
I, he's like, I don't care.
I personally think they are
murdering babies. I don't care. It's,
this was before that
trouble and this is one of the things
like when like that Parkland joke that he
did, I was like, look, that's
not his best joke, but it's also,
he's working it out yet then stand up in
10 fucking months. He's working it out.
But if you say that he's different now
we're getting to see the real Louis like
bitch, you better go through
his library. That's what he did.
Yeah. The apartment and was like
his ninth most offensive joke. Yeah.
Not even close. And he's, he's, that's
what he does. It's called comedy.
Yeah. They, the idea was like we'll put,
we didn't know he was, he didn't know him.
Yeah. Cause you know, you assume what
you believed, what he fed or you,
you wanted to believe.
I actually,
I have a theory that one of the reasons
people like the New York Times and, and,
and,
uh,
other media outlets got brought the hammer
down so hard on him is because they'd
heard the rumors and ignored them.
So now they have to signal
that like this is wrong.
Because there were rumors before and
they were like, we don't like they,
they ignore them. So now they have
to overcompensate and be like,
he is absolutely, he's the face of
hypocrisy and evil. I'm just like,
okay, well he just caught it at the
worst time. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
He just a bad,
he had beach front property
during a turn it, yeah.
Yeah. He just is like some arcades you
can just tell you got the deep stilts,
not this one mother fucker.
Like he had flush on sure. Flat.
He's walking around and I was
going, oh my God, this is my cup.
Oh my cup. Uh, here's what I
want to talk about with you.
The idea, cause whenever I tell people
were friends or that I go on your show,
they're like, how can,
I'm like, first of all,
because you're a fucking good dude and
have been a good dude for 27 years that I
know of. To me, um, it doesn't
mean you're always get whatever.
You're always good to do that.
Every time I said, whatever,
I don't fucking know your life.
I don't know what you do.
Outside of fucking Encino, uh, the, uh,
and now the next question becomes
why do you have cranks on,
or what people would
consider cranks on the show.
And you and I have talked about this a
little bit off the show. Explain because
you are basically liberal.
Yes.
But you believe in having hardcore right
wing people on because you like them
personally or you like you believe it's
worth some of them I like personally,
so it's worth having a conversation.
Like Ben Shapiro was one that
I had a long conversation with.
He's one of the more controversial guys
that I have on how people get upset at
me and call me an outrider. You mean
while he's been attacked by the alt right.
You know, I mean he wears a Yarmulke
for Christ sake and he's not alt right.
It's not a white supremacist by
any stretch of the imagination.
He was the number one target for
antisemitic remarks in the entire world.
2016. Well he's that. There's
that. It's definitely dead.
But we had an in depth conversation,
a very long one about gay people.
Yeah.
Cause he's a little bit of it where
he was like, he kind of didn't,
he kinda got a little lost.
Well, yeah, because it doesn't,
well he had two different
t here's David Parkman,
uh, had, uh, an interesting take on it.
Pacman said that if you
look at his explanation,
because I asked him a couple things,
I'm like,
do you really believe that Moses
part of the Red Sea? And he said,
I would look for more
naturalistic explanation for that.
But then when I talked to him
about gay people and gay things,
he wasn't interested in a
naturalistic explanation.
And he also wasn't interested in giving
people the ability to do whatever they
want. He felt like you're not,
you're supposed to resist that.
And his take is that like, you,
you have an urge to murder people,
but you don't do it because you're a
good person and you should do the same
thing with being gay. And I was like,
wow, that's crazy. That's crazy.
Mental gymnastics.
So that is a natch he believes the natural
occurring thing that God is testing
you with. I mean, I'm putting
words in his mouth. I think,
but essentially that's his position.
His position is that God doesn't want
you to do that. It's in the Bible.
He doesn't do it. I mean he, he goes hard.
He doesn't use electricity in the Sabba
till the sun goes down the whole deal.
Yeah. And um, you know, a
lot of people like, you know,
you've given this guy
a platform. Like, look,
I'm communicating with someone and I like
him as a person. He's a very nice guy.
I don't agree with them at all about that,
about the gays.
Don't you believe it's worth giving
people a platform? What does that mean?
I'm not platform,
but like I think that's a real problem
that discussing things like that,
like giving people a platform because
we're living in this world of DDI platform
with people.
I think that's inherently dangerous.
And I think that just stopping people
from their ability to communicate just
makes more pressure on their side.
It makes more people that are on the
fence support them because they see you as
being a sensor. And that's what I think
we found out with Jack. I'm from Twitter,
Jack Dorsey, when he came on and talk
to me about it and when he brought vid,
John Who's the lawyer and you know
like censoring, censoring, all sort of,
it's not smart,
it's not good.
It does the opposite of
what you intended to do.
It makes the other side magnified.
It makes whoever you're
censoring more popular.
It makes them an underdog and it also
goes against core American values,
like the freedom of speech.
And I know that these are private
institutions and I know that they are not
necessarily forced to uphold what we
determine as free speech in terms of like
how it's written in the constitution, the
bill of rights. I get, I understand that,
but I think that the principles of human
interaction on this planet are largely
dictated by our ability to discuss
things even if you disagree.
I actually do agree
with you that that the,
I think like d platforming and silencing
and he's at the danger. I don't,
there are very few people that,
well,
there's no one that I agree with 100% of
the time. Right. Including yourself. Yes.
Including your joke about like you
don't agree with yourself. Like I don't,
I don't, it's real. Yeah. Well that's
also, there's something Buddhist about it,
which is like your thoughts
are not correct. Right.
They're not even your thoughts.
They're just like pended upon your lotion.
Yes. It depends on your stress levels.
Yeah. You know, sometimes you just like,
you're, you just don't have it
in you and you're like stop.
And other times the same situation,
you'd be super calm and reasonable
and maybe you could turn it around.
Yeah. If you've eaten. Yeah. Like
there, I saw a thing yesterday.
Doctors are worse in the afternoon.
Oh,
I'm sure judges are worst hurt search
before surgeries in the morning. Uh, yeah.
So to your point,
yeah.
The right wing thing.
It's just an easy way to dismiss
me because I'm not right wing.
If you asked me my positions on
things, it's very left wing. Yeah.
The only thing that I very,
with the Orthodoxy is with the
Second Amendment with gun rights.
I don't think it's just that simple.
I know a lot of really good people
that have guns and I'll know,
I know a lot of really good people that
would never shoot anybody that have guns
to protect themselves and
to label everyone the same.
It's just like labeling everyone who
drives a car the same as those in cells
that drove into people in Montreal
or wherever that was. Who's that?
Toronto or wherever that was. Yeah, it's,
we have a real problem labeling people
and labeling people with it's lazy and
it's an attempt to marginalize
or dismiss their positions
and it also feels good.
Yeah.
Should do it should it feels good to
like guest what? Writing them off.
I'm superior.
I have a very clear moral view.
I'm taking out one of my moral
paint brushes, Chuang Tzu.
You are that.
Even if it's not a moral position,
even if like that Neal Brennan,
he's such a left wing cook. He's a this
and of that. And Boom, there you go.
I've got them in a box. I'm going to
put a ribbon on it. Yep. Ship them off.
So you've read the comments when I'm on
the chancel you're canceled. I heard.
Yeah. So, uh, I brought up
that makeup boy and, um,
the makeup of my daughter's in love with,
she watches this makeup on Youtube
and now he's been canceled.
I understand he lost 3 million and she's,
she was telling me to have an 11 year
old sit down and tell you about a gay
makeup artists and this is the funny part.
She goes,
well there was a couple of things.
Okay. So there was the thing with,
he has, um, a friend who,
and he tells me this woman's name who
got him into the business and then she
asked him to promote her hair stuff,
but he said no and he went with
another hairstyle. So he totally,
totally betrayed her.
All right.
It's like my 11 year olds telling me
this and then this was the best part.
She goes,
there was also some talk that he know
he's gay and there was boys that were not
gay and he tried to get them to be
in a room with him. It's just like,
well, listening to an 11 year
old. Tell me, by the way,
that also could have been how, that's how,
that's the tone of the Internet anyway.
It's an 11 year old girl,
so I'm actually heard at least it came
from an 11 year old girl instead of like
so and so's canceled.
You can like the yet. No,
you're a fucking 40 dope.
Don't,
why are you talking like a little girl?
You're on a fuck.
You're on buzzfeed or on Fox.
Like is he in the point where the New
York Times is going to be doing that?
Like it took close to it now? I
mean I think that Alabama, oh,
owns abortion people.
Yeah.
What it is is the media right now,
especially journalism,
they're fucking starving for hits. It's
so hard to make money. It's so hard.
And so they're drowning.
Yeah.
And so they're trying to grab
whatever branches they can. Yeah,
they got to make a good story with
it. Click baity title. Fuck it.
Deceptive title. Who gives
a shit? We got a good store.
That store is vetted and even
if it's not totally vetted,
if it's a little slippery, but that you
can make an amendment later, you know,
I'm sorry, we have a little bit an apology
and we have to make a retraction. Yeah.
Nobody reads those goddamn retractions.
No, you should have to have a retract.
If you,
if you fuck up so hardcore that you
attribute a crime to someone or you do
something like that and you'd
have to make it a retraction.
It should be on the front page of your
paper and nothing else for a month. Yeah,
that's it. This is your
newspaper now. Well, I'm sorry,
we don't get to tell you the news anymore
because we fucked this up so hard that
we printed out to millions of people
to just put in a little column in the
corner. Yeah, we'd like to,
Paul, we fucked up last
month also. Nine 11 happened
close though.
Planes wrote into the World Trade Center.
It's fucking too hard to be a
journalist, man. Well, that's what I,
this is another thing I want
to talk to you about, which is,
uh,
absolute meaning if you believe like,
I still believe in like institutional
journalists. I believe in New York Times,
I believe in Washington,
Washington Post, like so,
and you use the fact that
they wrote about a UFC fight.
They just said he was bloody and early
into Mcgregor fight where bloody and he
wasn't
just a bad, very bad description.
It was very inaccurate. I'm like,
why would you do that?
Like,
do you guys are crazy that the New
York Times is allowing this? Yeah.
Completely inaccurate description of
something that millions of people saw.
It's so silly and it makes everybody
question everything else you say.
And you might think it's trivial
because it's just a boxing match,
but it's completely inaccurate and
completely exaggerating what went down.
Well, if you've, you've had
articles written about you,
they fuck up everyone. Yeah.
Everyone.
Now having said that,
we can't dismiss all in like
there needs to be an absolute,
uh,
kind of an absolute truth.
And that's what I feel like is a sort
of melting in this era of anyone who was
like, well, they said
this and that's not true.
So everything else they say is fucking
bullshit of course. Which I think the,
the Trump does a lot and I think people
are all too happy to believe it because
they resent institutions. They resent
the smarty pants motherfuckers,
which I also get, I get the impulse, I
just don't think New York Times, right?
Yes. A smartness the old gray
lady. Yeah. Um, and it's like,
it just plays on every stereotype.
Like there are so many stereotypes of
work that can make you write it off.
I think we're in a transitionary
period. That's what I think. I think.
What do you think he gets replaced
by them. That's the real problem.
The real problem is they have all their
pieces, all the best journalists, right.
All the best people are all
locked into two ancient systems.
One ancient system is print medium. The
other ancient system is broadcast medium,
the broadcast medium.
The ancient product.
Part of it is it has to
go on at a certain time.
Tuesdays at 8:00 PM and then you have to
sit there and wait for the commercials
unless you DVR it. Right? Right.
So that's inherently flawed.
And then the print medium,
while they figured out a way to get it
on your laptop and your phone now, so,
okay, they've got a little
bit of a work around there,
but they have a really hard time
getting people to sign up for digital
subscriptions is that the distribution's
not nearly as good as it used to be and
it's hard. It's hard to get people to
buy newspapers, but at least they've,
they've got their foot
in the door with click.
Then I titles like the times and the post
are, are, are pretty successful online.
They're actually doing much better because
of president Trump because he talks
so much shit about them
that people x slate said,
I need to supply the New York
Times. What is, well they,
yeah, I'll check it out because they're
like, fuck man, this guy's child.
At times it's still irresponsible.
He's trying to match what I think might
have with abortion where it's like,
oh wait, whoa. I don't even
want to get it. But if you,
if this is where you motherfuckers were
headed, cause they were being held back,
it was like motherfucker,
I'll fuck you up.
And then they got free and now they're
beating the shit out of abortion.
People are like, Whoa,
accidental pregnancies or the
real problem. It's not even,
I mean obviously abortion is a
solution, right? If you have to,
if you want to do it.
But if the accidental pregnancies,
the real fucking problem
like it should be,
it's one of the things that I talked about
with Jesse Insel who was on the other
day,
we were talking about genetic engineering.
So like they're going to eventually one
day move away from sex for procreation
and sex is just going to be for fun,
which going to be people bonding
and enjoying each other's bodies.
That's not going to be how we procreate.
We're gonna,
we're gonna procreate through some
sort of, you like a girl naked calls.
It'll certainly drastically reduce the
amount of people that have kids, you know?
But what he said is everyone do you
freeze your eggs and like give sperm.
I don't know how they're going to do it.
I mean,
I think there's also the problem that
the baby's supposedly bonds inside the
mother's body.
Like to have a baby grow up in some
sort of a fucking weird electronic womb,
and then you make that
kid a fucking sociopath,
has no connection to people when he's
born. Doesn't give a fuck just to survive.
I mean, there was that test tube baby
thing, which I think started before me,
but I remember that being an insult. They
put the bid, the baby in the body, the,
they put the embryos in the person's
body and there is the thing of, uh,
surrogates. Yeah. So they, who do they
bond with? That's a weird one man.
Like that's,
that's the Kim Kardashian way now.
And she's having a bunch of babies
with surrogates. Like, you know,
you show up for the wedding or that you
show up for the birth in a fucking tight
skirt and like, Yay, my babies being
born today. Like, what? What you're,
you have your clothes on? What is
happening here now? She's, yeah,
I got a hired somebody,
my friend, I got a girl,
my friend actually did that and he's
gay and he and his husband, um, they,
they mix their sperm.
They shot it in the Turkey based
or something into some Gal.
I don't know how I am. I don't make an
excel file the science too tight. Anyway,
she got pregnant,
their surrogate got pregnant,
had the baby and decided to keep it
decided she couldn't part with it and it's
their baby.
So it's their DNA and mixed with hers.
And she decided to keep it and
uh, she got away with it, um,
sewer or they just were like, oh, I
don't know. I didn't want to push.
They were very upset and then they wound
up getting another surrogate and then
having a child and everything worked
out is quite a while ago. But uh,
they were really bummed out, man. I mean,
they were ready to be parents, but then,
you know, some people say, we will
do renewal, we're going to be purged.
The first blues crews were good,
noon, even have sex with him,
but it is their baby.
Right.
It's their DNA that made that based
on if they didn't adopt a child,
they chose to have
surrogates. So heh. Yeah. No,
it's complicated and getting
well that's the thing of like,
it feels like the level of danger and
difficulty in the world is just getting
steeper by the day.
We're like, wait a wow.
And then there's always global
warming and you're like, oh fuck.
Did you see a fucking the science guy,
Bill Nye going crazy screaming and he
was on the elevator or the planets on
fucking fire and yeah, let's get a little
silly. Yeah, I know. Never like Bro.
All right. Go to Antarctica.
Plants on fire, Bro. Uh,
no. I saw a thing that an artist that was
like 84 degrees. Oh my God. It's on fire.
I mean, yeah, it's really, do you really
see something that's in the Antarctic?
It was 84 nights.
Yeah.
Something in the Arctic circle is 84
degrees plus three days ago. Fuck that.
What it's going to be a,
it's gotta be,
do you ever think about
like global warming,
but really what it will look like,
like in 70 years,
what it will do to the art.
Like,
and I'm not talking about
just Miami's gone or any,
that's like incredibly like crazy
to think about. It's unfathomable.
Those Miami people, they're gonna
move other places and ruined.
That's probably the biggest, that's
my biggest worry. Definitely. He goes,
can we be Lamborghinis dudes yelling
at girls and Spanish eating outside.
Everyone's fucking eating outside, but
like, would you fucking get indoors?
You maniac though.
A lot of salsa.
I love going salsa and like North Carolina
like fuck Outta here. Salsa dancing.
Fuck out of here with the
fucking dead. Ain't bet. Then um,
that's a good bit there. Like another
country that's attached to Florida.
Yeah, it's like Europe. It's,
I always say it's like people do you
see like Italian people like in Beverly
Hills or Miami and the,
I would say to my friends,
those are people that were two
douchey for Ada Lee. They're like,
oh wait,
we got to take it to the next to
do she level Miami and then that go
deep. Uh, yeah, that, but,
but you think about like k,
I like, not like 28 days later,
but like, you know, like huge,
like scary.
Fucking scary.
Especially because we're going to
be near dead and no disrespect,
you're not going to be in the same shape
you're in now and you're not. You do,
I mean, people may give
you respect, but like,
it's going to be so fucking scary. We're
going to have to move to the mountains.
Where would you move to? Shit. Hit
the fan. Somebody. Sam, uh, who's,
what's Calvin's friend? Sam ciders.
Mind Sam seater? No, Sam. Uh,
the fighter's mind, he wrote him and how
can I not remember his name? Yeah. Um,
hold on one second. I'll tell you real
quick. This is going to be worth it guys.
Listeners, this is Tim.
Listen, Sam Sheridan. That's
right. Yeah, I'm sure. Um,
thank you.
Told me 10 years ago that stuck with me.
Go to the marina cause I live in Venice.
He,
he's like go to the marina and basically
just get basically you gotta pay to get
on a boat or just be like,
I will be the hard part
is how do I qualify too.
Like I can help you cause I get seasick.
Here's what I have going for me.
Seasick queasy because you just get away.
You get away from,
from La. Anyone you get
away from, uh, in Las case,
millions and millions
of people and you can,
if there's a attacker,
you can see them.
You assume that they're not
going to be like, you know,
seal teams coming onto your
boat. Attackers. Well, I
know, but that's what I mean.
Like how crazy could get,
yeah, you got to go to Alaska.
The how do you get there? It's good
call. I'll do, can you dry reports?
Closed airport. I mean I or lights
connected, right? You could drive.
You could technically drive. Yeah.
It cut off that road all the time.
And like the Napa Valley,
cause the landslide will Sharon.
We're gonna fuck you going
to go. Yeah. Good luck.
It's like Burger's got the helicopter
but he, it's, he's got to go to get it.
Yeah. That's his escape. A great bit about
that as black and white special. Yeah.
Yeah.
I would move north. I'd probably
move somewhere. That was a,
if I could get just go to a place,
if I knew I just had to get to a place,
I would go to a place that is sustainable.
Like uh,
whether it's Alaska or
Minnesota or Michigan somewhere.
There's a lot of animals and there's
wildlife and you have, you have cold,
you have water,
you have a lot.
Like cold is better than heat
because cold you can make a fire.
Like if you have shelter and you can
make a fire in the cold, you can live.
I have a cat
argument,
which is I don't,
I the cold kills more people
than he does hypothermia. Yes,
but that's just because you know,
people are unprepared for it.
You can prepare for cold with clothing.
You can't really prepare for
heat with clothing, with heat,
you need air conditioning
and you need water.
Those are two things that are
shade. Yeah. You need something.
If you live in like there's people
that have lived in very cold climates,
as long as they have a good house
and they have a good supply of wood,
they're fine. If you live in the
desert, man, you're kind of fucked.
You're kind of fucked.
If the power goes out,
you don't really have
anything to keep you cool.
You have to stay in the
shade and stay in doors,
but it's not good enough and it's 110
degrees inside. It's 125 hydrated though.
I don't think you will just die from
x from heat exposure. No you won't,
but you're not going
to find a lot of water.
One of the problems with global warming's
going to be that things like lakes,
lakes and streams are going to,
there's going to be less.
This gonna be less water is going to
be less dribbling down to the creeks.
Creeks, we're going to dry
up. Streams will dry up.
You're gonna have a hard time getting
water if you're in a desert environment.
If you have by by the same token,
if you have enough water,
you have as much water as you have wood.
Obviously the,
it's not a one to one analogy because
you can go get more would easily,
but if you had a shit load of water right.
If you just had like I hear your thought
about getting cold but I don't know if
I had shade.
I guess you don't.
I guess with cold you don't
have to have electricity,
you don't have to have electricity
with cold and also you have more of an
opportunity to find animals.
You'll find more animals in cold climates
and you're going to for delicious
animals for sure. Yeah, more
things to eat, but you might,
you could still easily starve to death.
Like the idea that it's easy to go out
there and shoot a bunch of animals and
eat them all the time,
like not most places.
Most places you don't have an
abundant enough supply of wildlife.
You're also a guy who does archery.
Yeah,
I know how to do you have skills for
this and I would still be panicked.
I'd be like, fuck, this is not good.
If I had to feed my family with a bow
and Arrow, first of all, I'd say, okay,
how many hours do I have? I would have
to make sure that I have enough arrows.
I mean, you have to practice
to is not like a rifle.
If I have a hundred rounds,
I can kill a hundred things.
I don't really need to practice
that much of my rifles on off.
I can have good triggered discipline.
I'll pull through the shot, I'll,
I'll try not to flinch and I'm not
going to take any unreasonable.
I have no fucking idea what
you're telling me. Shooting.
You don't want to anticipate.
I anticipate you don't want to
flinch when the trigger goes up.
So a lot of guys like Tim Kennedy,
who's a friend of mine who's a one of
the baddest motherfuckers in the world,
he'll practice with dummy rounds.
So he has regular bullets and then
four bullets are just not real bullets.
So it's like bang, Bang, Bang, click,
and then the has to get rid of that,
that bullet.
But he leaves.
He knows if he was flinching
because if you're flinching,
you'll see this movement where there's no,
no gun goes off.
The boat doesn't go off,
but you make that weird mood because
you're anticipating in the shot.
That's the way to train
yourself out of it. Yeah.
You have to do something like that.
You have to have what's called trigger
discipline. Well, first of all,
trigger discipline means don't
put your finger on the trigger,
but also the way you squeeze. You got
to just squeeze, squeeze, squeeze,
squeeze and let the shot go off
by surprise and not react to it.
It's the same thing with a bow and arrow.
You have to have a surprise shot.
You want, you wanted to just do
want to concentrate on the target,
zone it in and which feels like
you kind of can't even be there.
Meaning like you just have to be
like, I'm doing a thing. You know,
like you can't think about the release.
You have to just think about the
target that's very astute of you.
There's actually courses is a guy named
Joel Turner who has this whole course
called a shot Iq. He's
a, he teaches um, um,
first responders like swat teams and
shit without trigger discipline and about
how to, how to shoot properly
under pressure. And uh,
he works with people with archery for
this sit with the same thing cause it's a
psychological thing to,
but my point is with a bow and Arrow,
you're kind of fucked you,
you need a lot of Goddamn arrows and you
need to make sure that bone is going to
stay okay with all the animal
to like, like a deer, deer,
deer or bear would be like
the most edible thing. Yeah.
You want to bear if you have a bear,
you could eat that motherfucker for a
long time and you can take that fat and
you could render the fat down, use it
for cooking and use it for, you know,
you could do, do a lot of things with
it. And that meat is a lot of meat.
Anything big, you want a big animal
because you want to be able to dry it out,
make jerky.
You want to have something that's going
to sustain you for a few days or weeks
until you find another animal.
You're gonna want to dig a hole in the
ground to make some sort of cold storage.
You want to get below like
the frost line. Yeah, you got,
you got to protect it from
other bears. Yeah, you got it.
You're going to have to do a lot of
things and you're probably not gonna make
enough food. It sounds hard.
It's the hardest the eye.
Every time I go on a hunting trip,
I always think like,
imagine if this is the
only way I could get food.
It's so God damn hard to get close
to an animal. It's so hard. Yeah.
People see videos of it like on youtube
and there's the deer and you draw your
bow back and you hit it in the
heart and the deer's down. Everybody
said,
well,
you don't see as days and days
of writing all day long. Just go.
If you could watch from a live
stream of the moment of hunt,
start to the moment you're successful
and you just sat through the whole thing.
Look as a fucking games of Thrones
marathon, then you would understand it,
but even then you wouldn't really, cause
you wouldn't be out there in the cold,
exhausted,
hiking uphill going thousands of feet
up and down and elevation and then the
wind shifts and the deer smells you
and it starts off, you're like, fuck,
it's hard man. It's like tedious.
And to survive off of that,
see I'm doing it for my own food, but if
I don't get a deer, I'm going to live.
I'll go to a restaurant.
If you're only option is deer that you
catch and kill and find your shot or
sick. Oh my God. And he got
to fucking catch a deer.
That's um, that's when you wonder,
you know, you wonder how am I gonna,
what am I going to watch
them starve to death?
That must've been really exciting for
native Americans or just any ancient
people of just like getting
like kit. Like, you know,
I think we could kill above.
Hello? Yeah, we all like,
we all have to be fat.
Like we all have to team up and
that's why humans have survived.
But like it must've been so
fucking like at celebration,
like in he walks celebration,
you know it's crazy to this day there
are these areas where they find a lot of
arrowheads because they would
drive these buffalo off cliffs.
How fucking nuts is that?
Like they know the spots where they
would drive them off cliffs and fall down
and sometimes the bodies with
decay cause I didn't eat all of it.
They a hundred buffalo fly off a cliff
is only a thousand native Americans in
this spot with the fuck are they gonna do.
They're gonna eat as much as we can.
But the rotten ones literally exploded
and caused a forest fire in one area.
They think a forest fire was caused by a
rotting pile of buffalo that eventually
exploded like a whale explosion.
I like that kind of deal.
Google that makes sure that's not horse
shit cause it sounds like a lie coming
out of my mouth.
They believe that a rotting pile of
bison was responsible for starting a fire
here because that's how the,
cause they found like all this
chard like stuff and they're like,
they were trying to piece it together.
If I remember the story of properly.
And I think they were like,
this might have happened because
the body's rotted so much.
They exploded and it started fuck.
Cause it's like you have the gasses
Muldez rotting tissue. Like, you know,
whales explode on the beach. I
splatter on people. Yeah. Fantastic.
So they're trying to take
this to a next level,
like how much heat would be
generated by all this bacteria?
Like what kind of explosion
could this make? Yeah.
And also why would the explosion,
is it a spark caused,
I would assume it's gooey methane
gases and rotten gases. Yeah.
Like they would have to be some, something
to ignite, you know, those little
um, uh, arrowheads. They find you're
supposed to leave them in a lot of places.
If you find you're supposed to
leave him there just for like,
luck or something for you,
go fuck yourself.
I ain't leaving shit arrowhead.
Like, Oh, you have to lead it. Words.
Guns fucking going up there. Yeah. Where
is it going? Like where's if I leave it,
someone else can pick it up on you think
the good man have a good person to pick
it up. You have to leave it here.
No, no, no, you can't have it.
Is that like the parks commissioners are
native and I know when I was hunting in
Nevada they said that if you found
an arrowhead yet to leave it there.
I was like, Huh, okay. Oh, you know what?
I haven't talked to you about
what the doing these big venues.
Oh Arenas. Yeah. That's weird.
How do you like it? It's fun, man.
San Diego was a lot of fun.
It's um, it's strange though.
It's a lot of God damn people.
Does it feel like disconnected now?
Not didn't surprisingly.
San Diego is interesting.
Like the people that were in the
front, they were right there, man.
It was [inaudible] 7,000 now
San Diego was 12 something,
almost thirteen thousand thirteen
thousand unbelief. It's a lot of people.
And they was in the round.
Yeah, that was weird too.
And did you have a plan? Nope. But yeah.
No cause like she can't
really think about,
you can't worry about the people that
are behind you. You can't, you got,
well they have giant screens everywhere
so everybody got to see you. Um, I,
I definitely was aware of the magnitude
of the show and I did a lot of sets that
we, I do like eight, nine sets
that week before I did it.
Like the funny thing was I
didn't understand, I was like,
how is he not selling this out? And
then I saw victor, then I was like, oh,
it's a fucking arena. I was like, I
thought Joe was as popular as ever been.
And then I'm like, why is this guy posted
so much? And then I'm like, oh, cause it's
hard to get that last last
thousand. I know. And you're still,
you can't,
the,
I dunno if it's the human mind are
like the competitive comedy mind,
but like can't leave it alone.
You want that fucking thousand.
Like you want to hear sold out.
Yeah. Like doesn't like, yeah,
but you don't want to go sell Joe
Rogan 12,000 people. You have a woods.
It holds like 12, nine.
Yeah. Aw, what a pussy.
Can't even get 900 more people like
you bro. And you would kind not,
you would think it's a failure,
but you would always be like, yeah,
Josh Wolfe showed me a picture once of
him on stage open enough for Larry the
cable guide in front of 50,000.
Jesus, he did a football stadium.
Jesus get her done. Well that's
what Kevin Hart does. Those big,
I mean he did his uh,
one of his Netflix buses,
like 49,000 people. Some
fucking insane. If, I mean that,
I wouldn't want to see that shit.
I wouldn't want to go to that weird
third balcony. Like what do you even,
I mean, I don't know. People like
communal experiences like that. Yes.
I think that's a good way to put it.
But like when venues 50,000,
you're just far away.
Yeah.
But I guess if you like the jeans and
everyone's in there together, it's,
you've created a culture.
So people go to be a part of the culture.
Kevin's created the culture.
Larry, the cable guy, created
a culture. So people go,
it's like to be around their brothers
and sisters. Kind of kind of,
I mean straight up though,
like not like it's even intentional.
That's the thing I like about podcasting
as a successful medium and your
podcasts in particular
is like the shit you're,
you're into comedy,
you're into fucking weed,
you're into you,
fos and the unexplained,
you're into government conspiracies,
you're into a gender issues. You're,
you're legitimately into all this stuff
and you created a tent where everybody
feels like welcome, like, hey, it's going
to talk about the thing that I'm like,
you're interested in a lot of
shit. Generally. You're not going,
I'm only interested in comedy or, or
more niche about it. You just like this,
you're into, you're intently inventions
and fire and guns and hunting.
You're just into a bunch of
shit legitimately and you
express it and people love
it.
Well that's it.
Was gene actually being into shit and
talking about things you're into versus
talking about the things
you think will be popular,
right? Yeah. You kind of, you
can't, you can't do that for,
I guess you see, I can't think of anyone
could, but you'd get off the top of your,
off the top of my head who that would be.
But it'd be obvious that you
weren't really tuned in. He wouldn't be
really interested in it. You're not, you,
you wouldn't be as enthusiastic.
Yeah.
And you are genuinely,
you only have on people that you genuinely
like or genuinely interested in and
doesn't matter if they're famous,
not famous,
like whatever controversial,
not controversial.
Like it's just shit that
you're into your expressing.
It's the,
the another reason why I like pockets,
it's like watching someone exist.
Yeah.
It's like an expression of your
subconscious or your, your brain.
Like it's like the typical day in your
brain. I'm just like, I like this.
And then I go over here and then I go,
Duh.
And you and you've been
able to like do it in a way,
which is why it's so popular is like it
is popular but it's not even the right
word.
It's like resonant with people.
Yeah.
I think for a long time people have been
doing shows where the show was produced
and there's a bunch of people behind
the scenes and whatever that person is,
it's,
it's almost more difficult for them to
get their personality to shine through
all that shit. But if it's just stuff
that you're really interested in, yeah.
Then people get up
and it's also be like, and then it's a
girl takes off and Burt takes off. And uh,
who,
who am I forgetting the Joey takes off.
I didn't know how long you've been
friends with Joey, Joey guys, friends
for 23.
Yeah.
Theo like guys that you just genuinely
like, like that they're just kind of like,
even the,
the,
the like the sober October
thing or like it's, you know,
the numbers are massive. Yeah. It's cause
it's just, it's like a show. It's like a,
I know it's everybody's a character
and it's like an old radio play.
Like here comes fucking Bert Kreischer.
He think he acts out something
called the Mickey Mantle. Jay,
what the hell is it Mickey mantle
thinking about like, everybody's got like,
it's set up and it's,
it's not like it's sloppy in a fun way.
Yeah. And uh, and it's cool and
you get to reap all the reward,
all the guys that are
responsible for the cause.
The other thing is so many times,
this is the first time, like in,
in certainly in media history where guys
are in charge of their own everything.
Yeah. Like you own the labor. I
mean, there's not even a layer.
That's just my thing there.
Artists tried,
like the Beatles had a record label and
they would bring people on and then they
would, they, it always got
fucked up every single time.
And this I feel like is the first time
where it's like, Sigur has got like,
you know,
his umbrella now he's got like his,
he's got his spinoffs and uh,
it's fucking excellent.
It's just excellent.
It's so great.
I was talking to a guy who used to be in
charge of at Viacom and we were talking
about, you know, when they, when
people do shows now, like, you know,
they'll pay, uh, Kenny Barron, so they'll
pay, Sean arrived and the pay Dave Allen,
Chris, all these guys, like 20 million,
the writers get a hundred buddy of mine,
Mike Schur created good place and,
um,
parks and rec and he's getting 25 mil
a year for the next five years. Yeah.
And it shows aren't hits his heart.
His shows are picked up and successful,
but they're not like cheers. Right.
Wow. Um, and I said to Doug
Herzog, the guy from flag, I go,
how much were you fucking guys
making before? What were these,
what were these companies
making 20 years ago?
Like what was ABC making
20 years ago that they,
and they even Seinfeld said that he,
he's like,
I was the first one to get a hundred,
uh, million an episode. And I go,
which is a pittance compared to what
they could have paid you. And he's like,
I know that now,
but back then $1 million in and Ah,
what are you even going to deal with it?
And now it's like what are they gonna do
with it? What the fuck they were making?
They were making 100 million in episode,
but because it's a logo and a corporation
go, well that's what a corporate,
it's supposed to make $100 million
and a half is up. Meanwhile,
if a guy makes a million, you're
like, what are you going to,
it's like this unfathomable thing.
It's like where they get mad at basketball
players and not the owners of the
teams.
Yeah.
And it's also that distribution model of
like putting something on a network is,
there's so much fat,
there's so many people,
the silly things that you have to pay
so much, so many different places.
The money goes,
it's almost like you have to make $100
million an episode for everybody to make
out. Yeah. But also, no, they don't live,
but also they're still taken 90 yeah.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Even with all
the revenues with all like the, the, the,
uh, all the miles, I got a fade. It's
still like a huge profit. But as a writer,
do you think that like investing your
time and effort into a Sitcom today?
It's like, well, good luck with
that. I don't, dude. I like,
I just started, I, we used to
do the podcast may emotionally,
this podcast called the
champion was great. And uh,
and now I just started one like a
month ago called how Neil failed.
Look for it and you look up things,
um,
how Neil you'll feel and that's the
name of the pocket, got a theme song.
Everything's very sick. Um, but it
was, I was like, why am I trying,
I did it a pilot like a year ago for a
network and they gave me notes and I was
like, oh, I forgot about notes. Oh,
I forgot that they were going
to give me notes. Like, Ugh,
like I don't just let me,
that was the always the thing that me
and Dave got to with comedy central and
they finally left the salon after
like six episodes where I was like,
let us show it to the audience and
let them decide. We don't want a bomb.
We want to bomb less than you
guys do. Trust me. Trust me.
You've never met two people who
want to bomb less than me and him.
And so they'd be like, well, we don't
end up like, let's show to the crowd.
If they like it, then
great. And if they don't,
then we sh they that we did this
real world sketch and they didn't.
They were like, we just think it's a
bunch of unfunny scenes back to back.
And we're like,
let's just show it to the crown.
And then we showed it killed
and they were like, all right,
we don't know what we were talking about.
They literally said,
we don't know what we're talking about.
So do whatever you want.
Unfunny what a fucking God.
Oh,
those people. But that's the, I get that.
They feel like they have to do something.
Yeah.
But we're with comedians are willing
to like all our skin's in the game.
It's all, it's all of our,
it's our hide every time.
So why do you feel the need to
like correct us or I don't mind if,
uh, if like an executive is like the
first audience, do you know what I mean?
Or like, Hey, your shirts fucked it,
whatever. Like, like in minor stuff.
But it's like material wise,
most of you are not good at defining
what's special about somebody or what's an
innovative segment or
you know what I mean?
Like they don't even think about that.
They just,
they're ambitious people who are just
like working their way up a thing and
they're like, is it my
turn yet? I get to fucking,
I get to put my stamp
on it now. Yeah. Yeah.
I want to add something even
if it's irrelevant, like be,
I had a joke when we were doing half
baked and then going two for two day,
but uh, we're doing half baked
and I said to David, God,
we should do a thing at the end where,
um,
we should just say, hey,
let us do whatever we want.
And in the end we'll pass a hat around
and you guys can take credit for something
because ultimately that's what you want.
You want to be able to take
credit for something, right?
Well don't fucking make us do it.
I know you just want credit.
That's all you want.
You just want to feel good about yourself.
You want to feel like I
contributed to this thing,
but let us just let us do the thing.
You know what I mean?
And if you're like you who've just been,
how long you been doing the podcast?
Almost 10 years.
It'll be 10 years in December,
you're going to do a big network show
about him kind of networked anniversary,
Special Ham radio.
That's hilarious.
I've been thinking about taking over
an am radio station for the day.
That's so fun. That'd be
really fun. So let me, um, the,
uh, wonder if they'd let me,
but even like in when we used to do it in
your house, you know what I mean? Like,
and it's like,
that was a long time ago.
You were on you on an episode
at least seven years ago. Yeah.
Oh yeah. I did too. In your
house. That was back in the kids,
be in the background yelling at each
other and shit here in the hall.
And they were a little
crazy. Um, one 14. Wow.
Episode one 14. How many?
That's two years. Year and
a half. And yeah, probably.
What does episode now?
What is 1297 [inaudible] 98.
That was 98. Now this is number
one, two, nine, eight. No,
[inaudible] 98 when the
podcast and started hundred
episodes 1100 episodes ago.
Yeah. And it's from, look at me. I'd a
Fohawk lucky you. Beautiful bastards.
Fog 80% nos.
That was before I realized they should
put a beard on where a little bit more,
a little scruff. Um, podcasts are a
very, very strange thing, man. It's,
it's just this,
no one saw this coming and
everyone can start one,
but I don't even think you saw it
coming. Do you know what I mean? Like,
I don't call him, I didn't see this. Yeah.
Like presidential candidates
from my fucking show. Telsey
Gabbert on yesterdays.
Yeah. Running for president.
I didn't watch it, but yeah,
I wanted to talk about real issues that
affect the world. I'm like, Oh yeah. Uh,
yeah. And I'm sure do you feel, I mean,
you Kinda can't change your ethos.
You can't be like, I'm a role model
and I need to know, no, it's not.
No, no, no. I'm just going to be me. You
know, and the world's going to be weirder,
but it's just me.
But it's also the thing of like,
when you're in these like development
TV movie worlds and you're like,
just let me talk.
Just fucking lie.
Like I promise it'll be interesting.
Like it won't all be interesting,
but it'll be interesting enough. It'll be
interesting enough. Often enough. Yeah,
that just let me talk.
Why couldn't imagine given up that
reigns to someone now, like if a,
all of a sudden we brought in some sort
of a producer or a network, just like,
look, we're going to take this
podcast to the next level,
but you got to listen to me Joe Show
where I'm not sure that you did with Ilan
Moscow.
One of the great reasons that that show
was very successful as the way you were
dressed.
Yeah,
I know you don't like to hear this and
we tested it had nothing to do with him
being weird and smoking weed and having
a fucking, having a claim for our shirt.
You wore a nice shirt is,
I mean is there even like there's,
you could never decide.
You can never test like whether
podcasts going to be successful,
you can now just,
it's all,
it's all a word of mouth.
It's just weird fucking,
they like it. They like it. Like
a conversation like this. Yes.
We're actual real friends. So when we
talk it's very evident. We have chemistry,
what's known as a chemistry.
Yes. I can try that. That's
right. Normal. Yeah. Yeah.
Like right here and joining
your time here on this earth.
Well that's the thing.
Doing so doing this and I told,
I remember telling somebody like,
it's like doing the tonight
show in [inaudible] 78
interviewed in terms of like,
I was in Singapore and a guy came
to the show who saw me on that.
Like every it's, you can't, it's not
even worth knowing if you're, you.
It's like fucking don't worry about
it. Just show up and talk. But uh,
I can't pay attention to that. Yeah.
By paralyzing. Yeah. But the, uh,
so I'm like,
the funny thing is when you do TV,
when you do something that's going to
be seen or heard by this many people,
like a TV show. If I do Seth or
the daily show, like I prep this,
I'm like, fucking, yeah. I don't know.
We talk about like so many times,
I'll run into you at the store and we
basically have like a 10 minute podcast in
the hallway. Yeah. You know, we just start
talking. You'll say you seen this? Yeah.
You pulled me aside. Like if you ever
heard about ketamine, I'm like, what?
And then all of a sudden you're telling
me you're taking ketamine session.
And that's the thing. If
there's no, you can't prep.
And it would be odd you couldn't
explain it to people 10 years ago.
Like it'll just be people sitting
and talking. Now the, the,
the comedians are by
nature pretty entertaining.
At least talkative. Yeah. At least
pretty talkative. And at, at, at,
uh, and on the high end, entertaining
and funny, he had the worst advice.
He's like, you go to [inaudible]
doing it for an hour,
just do it one hour and edit it.
Yeah. I'm like, all right. Now,
you know, uh, when people
turn it off or anything, nope.
Um, I know that the average time
that someone watches on Youtube,
we know that, which is like
what, 35 minutes or so.
35 minutes on Youtube,
which is a lot. Yeah,
that's it because the average is
like 15 seconds. But yeah, the APP.
What's a normal average on you?
Two, three or four minutes. Yeah.
Flick for everyone that
watches for 10 seconds.
There's someone that watched it for
an hour and a half or three hours.
So the average would be like three or
four minutes for a normal channel. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well you know the difference between
something on Youtube and something
that's a podcast that you're
listening to though I think the,
the people that are listening are,
I don't want to say this, I'm not,
I don't know if it's really true,
but they might be more invested in like,
cause they're subscribing
to it and they're listening
to it in their car on the
way to work. They're listening to. A
lot of times when they're at the gym,
people on Youtube can flip the and decided
to go to the next and what's this and
that, and then they get, you don't get
taken down a rabbit hole with podcasts,
with audio podcasts. You just listen,
you listen to one of your other.
Whereas Youtube, like you could stumble
upon this accidentally. Right now.
Someone might be stumbling upon this
very video right now on youtube.
Welcome. Welcome, welcome friend.
The same for you, bitch. Ah,
the other thing you forget is how
much people fucking drive. Yeah.
We're the like, I'm in my car for
hours a day. You're like, what? Why?
And they're like, and, and you are
their friend. Yeah. That's weird.
Do you know what I mean? Like
you're there, whether you,
it's like you don't know them,
but you,
they really like you and they feel
like they have a connection with you.
Yeah. And all the other people that like
you and Theo and Dileo, whoever's here,
you know, people that come in. Yeah.
Then those people become characters
in their little world play as well.
Yeah. Like, you'll see it
in the comments, but like,
this fucking skinny fuck is like
literally like this. Talk me back.
They read the [inaudible]
was the last time I did it.
The comments were so bad and I
didn't even you or you texted me.
I was like, boy, they must be very
bad because you were like, we ma,
we did something right or something. I was
like, well, they must be awful. And then,
uh, uh, I didn't cause I know what
they're going to say. It's like,
what do you think? I'm
dumb. I'm not a dumb.
You got to say whatever you
think of me. I'm not dumb. Right.
So I disagree with you politically. All
right. I don't, you know, like I don't,
I don't eat right.
That's one of the reasons why I bring
people on that I don't agree with.
I think it's important to have
conversations with people,
whether on the left or the right,
that you don't agree with.
Just to find out who they are
and what they think. Yeah.
And just to have discussions,
testing your own feelings about a hundred
percent just like, okay, no, that's,
that's all right.
I still feel having heard arguably
their best argument or a very cogent
arguments for their side and
you go, Yep, I think that,
I think the thing that is lost in our,
in one of the things that's
lost in the world now is, um,
because of I partially because of
the internet or blogs or whatever,
where you have to be 100% in every
belief and it's like I'm not 100% in any
belief. No. Like I'm like, I,
there are some beliefs where I say I'm 50,
I'm 51% and but that still wins.
51% is still the thing I tell you where
if people can't believe you either gotta
be 100% or zero,
you're a cock whore,
you're a fucking stud. Like,
uh, and there's no like,
yeah, well abortions of perfect example
where we're both like, I'm for it, but,
but it's pretty brutal or it's pretty,
it's a severe thing or whatever.
The Butt and you're not allowed to
have a button anymore. You can't,
you just can't go.
I haven't measured point of view and it's,
I took the vote in my head and it's 70,
30 and you're not,
and it can change your mind somehow or
another. That's bad. That's my whole,
someone said, well, not just one person.
Many people said you flip
flop on things like, no,
I consider things and it changed my life.
So not when politicians do it,
it's because they,
it's politically in that going
to work in their favor. Yeah.
You do it because you've thought more
about it or you heard the right argument
at the right time and just got okay.
Yeah, I changed my opinions
all the time. I don't, I don't,
I'm not married to those fucking
things. I don't need them. You know,
my opinions are just the ideas in my
mind or something that should be explored
and there's certain ideas that I
just hold steadfast. Don't rape,
don't murder people. Don't steal
all the obvious ones. Right?
Everybody holds those. Yeah. But then
when it gets to a unusual, weird,
slippery things, I'm like,
okay, well what is why?
Why is there an inclination to
lean towards a certain direction?
Like what do we virtue signaling are we,
you know,
we are sending out the flag of tribal
obedience and what are we doing when we're
discussing these things?
And a lot of that is what ruins discourse.
And this is what I think. I have a
real big problem with deep platforming.
We started d platforming
people in censoring people.
You don't just want to not hear them,
you want no one to hear them.
And this is where I have a problem.
It's because who the fuck are you?
Like why are you the one who gets
to say even if they're wrong,
even if they're won't let everybody
figure it out. It's missing
formation. That's the thing. It's
like pizza gate or one of the,
like Alex shall be saying like,
dude, what the fuck are you doing
to gain is a good example, right? Because
people get ramped up in it. They're like,
what? And there was a guy, Ben Swan, who
is a, uh, a journalist who had all these,
he was,
he had this video that he put out that
showed like all the different connections
with conspiracy theory or
with pizza gate and, uh,
various conspiracies and pedophilia.
And it was, it was a real weird one.
And everybody was like, what? Well, it's
just because these things are similar.
It doesn't mean there's a pedophile
ring going on. They're like,
what is that exactly is happening there?
But then you hear about someone like
Jimmy Saville and you go, wait a minute,
wait a minute with this guy was fucking
kids for how long? Yeah. And no one, like,
how are there any other ones right
now that they have it exposed?
You know what I mean? Like that kind of,
that kind of shit does, I don't having,
yeah,
I think there's a big, there's
a ton of distance between, uh,
there are pedophiles and there
are pedophiles in the pizza in the
basement. Yeah. Like there, I
believe there's pedophiles. Right.
And that they should be stopped and
they're mostly, yeah. And I, my bed is,
I don't think none of
them are powerful in that,
but I don't think that there is a,
uh,
I just don't really buy into conspiracies.
Just generally buy in some, cause
there's some of them that approvable,
there's some of them that really did
happen where you go, Jesus Christ,
they really did that. There's no,
yeah, I mean like, like, like in,
in like third world countries where
will fuck with elections, like salmon,
the shit like that. Like that is, yeah.
Like that's not even a conspiracy.
That's just like a poorly
told part of history.
That's our goal Shit Tonkin and said,
oh yeah, yeah, yeah. But that's,
I think that's, well, I
think that's, uh, out,
you know what I mean? Oh yeah. Um, do
you know about the operation Northwoods?
Do you know about that one?
I don't know.
That one's probably the most disturbing
one because that one was signed by the
Joint Chiefs of Staff.
They were going to organize a bunch of
attacks on America and blame the Cuban so
that we could go to war with Cuba.
They were going to arm KeyVault families
and have them attack one Tanam obey.
They were going to blow up a
jetliner and blame it on Cuba.
They had all these plans and it was signed
by the Joint Chiefs of staff and then
vetoed by Kennedy. He was like, what the
fuck are you? What are you guys doing?
You guys?
I went to fucking Hyannis port and I come
back and try to blow up airplanes and
the thing is it's, this is something that
didn't fly, but we found out about it.
How many of these things we didn't find
out about that actually did happen and
that we think are legitimate instances
in the news or real attacks and I just
turned out to be false drop in the bucket.
It's a drop in the bucket.
I think it's less than 1% in comparison
to actual events, actual reality per se.
And so when, when people are the reason
I don't like conspiracy theories,
I think it people use it to explain
their own failure a lot of the time.
Like we say it a lot in comedy, like,
well, you can't make it unless you're a,
oh goodness, be warm. And you're
like, all right man, that's not just,
I hate that fucking, that perspective
is so crazy. It's like, listen,
if you're killing people are going
to see you. If you kill a lot,
people go to see you a lot.
It's that simple. You can't
fake it is a meritocracy.
It really is.
And it's v like there are,
there are certainly like some
quota of stuff in the margins,
but not, no one's making it. Uh, no
one's doing arenas because of, uh,
the quote you can't pull.
There's nothing you can do to get into
arenas yet people have to actually like
you. Um, and this,
this excuse making that people
do do as a straight white man.
I can't get a break in his town alert.
Oh my God.
When you're a straight white man and
you're complaining like you got one of the
most fucking captivating hands
of cards in world history,
world history in 2019 straight
has still a great hand.
You might get beat with a crazy,
uh,
you know Nan that.
Yeah.
And then that hand out at the hamstrings,
man, that'll get you on the river.
I know she got number one. It wasn't
even funny. Yeah, the fuck. Ah,
man. What's anti-car alright. Uh,
my take on it and then that thing and
I haven't even seen it. It's like,
do people like it? Yeah. Good. I saw live.
Did you like it? Yeah, I liked it a lot.
Nice. It's like I saw in New York,
I saw before it was on Netflix.
Like I saw it and met her and was like,
thought I was really nice.
It was an awkward conversation. I'll say
that. Well, she is a little spectrum me,
right? Isn't that, I think that's a
fair, pretty open about estimation. Yeah.
Like it was, it was, it wasn't like easy.
Do you find that you, when you
speak to certain women, particular,
you feel like almost like you're
guilty of something like you,
like you're a male, like you're
an oppressor. Do you ever,
you ever not too many women
and it could just be a project.
It could be my own. It could be. I'm
like auto projecting where I'm like,
I definitely do that.
There aren't too many,
but I think you have to work
against stereotypes. You're
working against tattoos,
built bald,
right wing podcasts.
Well cage fighting commentator.
I forgot about that. Cheeses,
Joe. Yeah. So like you have
a lot. I'm pretty, you know,
a feet. The way I look is a
problem. It's like I and I, if you,
what are the odds? You're not sexist
or a dickhead. Yeah. Not that good.
Like what are the odds like,
so, uh, you try, I mean I don't,
I don't feel it too much,
but I can imagine how much,
what percentage of women do you
feel like you have to do that?
With the ones who don't know me,
once they know me, like I'm pretty,
pretty nice. Like go to a venue, you go
to the venue that you've never been to.
There's a woman,
the backstage,
one of the works for live nation or she
works the venue like does she assume
that you're not if they worked for our
nation, I'm nice to all those folks.
But I think that if someone has,
uh,
like a very staunch feminist perspective
and they meet someone like me,
they might, depending upon
their perspective, they might
think that I'm the enemy.
That that's a,
that's a possibility.
That like right away they looked
at me like the enemy. Yeah.
Well that's the thing of like,
what are you absolute like even,
and you, you can tell sometimes
when you're arguing with,
with people that are super dogmatic
about whatever they believe in,
let they can,
you can watch them go into a line of
logic that they know that they then
realize,
I can't cause that will like a seed,
some ground to this person. They go, Duh.
And it's like I saw you start to
go down that like a, just a reason.
And I'm not saying d, uh, stop
believing what you believe.
And it's just like, it's,
you doesn't have to be 100% exactly.
Just, it's fine. You can still,
you're still win the popular vote.
It's majority rules.
It doesn't have to be
overwhelming. Just, just don't,
it's dishonest in a way because
they don't want to believe.
They don't want to have,
uh,
they don't wanna have a chink in
their armor in terms of logic.
Yeah. To want to lump people
into categories because
it's easy to define them to,
you know, uh, we were goofing yesterday,
me and Joe List were goofing around
about a Alyssa Milano sex strike and she
choose for those enough.
And I was like,
one of the things that's offensive
about that is first of all, that, um,
that women would agree with you that
they would just withhold sex from the
person that they'd allow
us. Some Alana said, guys,
I'm Alyssa Milano said you should
withhold sex because in fucking Georgia
they're limiting abortion laws.
But the second thing is,
I like that you would assume that
all men are responsible for this,
not even just the voters in Georgia,
but all men.
Somehow I got a man in Minneapolis
should be denied sex from his progressive
for that. He's going to call like
his friend in Alabama. Like, man,
this is some, cause I'm not
getting no pussy up here bro.
This fucking sex strike is for real,
Bro. This is hitting us. So it's so good,
delusional and such a dumb flag of
virtue that they're throwing up and it's
such, it's such stupid 2019
woke politics. That was okay
by the way. It's like based
on lots of Strada like uh, uh,
old Greek play wasn't really. Yeah,
no shit. Those are sec striking it.
Yeah. And that's what that
movie Shairaq was about. It
was, it was a sex strike. No,
in Chicago. Yeah. Did that work?
It's an I don't think it's ever,
I don't know. Will you Google and
see if it's ever been done? Um,
imagine the girls are just use it as
excuse to not fuck a guy. They won't,
don't want to fuck. It's also like, come
on. So most of them aren't fucking anyway.
It's like, yeah, like what are you going
to take? Rock had that joke about like,
what are you going to, you can't stop.
You're already not fucking me to die.
When you hear, we hear women talk about
not wanting to fuck their husbands.
It's like, it's such a depressing, like I
was listening to this Gal, she was like,
well, you know, most wives don't
want to have sex with their husbands.
Like what you listen to that you're like,
Ugh,
as a husband at bumps you out.
Or as a, as a human being,
humans and the learn a situation without
the thing that people liked the most
about relationships. But besides the
fact that he loves someone to care,
someone is having sex with somebody
who wants to have sex with you.
It's great fun. It's a fun
time. It's very rewarding.
It's feels real nice.
Phil's Chris specially take a little hit.
See if we really feel
it. Yeah, it feels great.
So when you hear that someone
doesn't want that and then you know,
and their attitudes that
most women don't want that.
Most women don't have sex
with their husband. They just
do it cause they have to.
Well that's also,
it's very hard to get a clear story about
women and sexuality in that. Like it's,
I don't,
I think it's varies from wildly.
Oh, for sure. Like he hasn't
been girls you've dated. Yeah.
Even the other day I put a thing
on, on, uh, Instagram where I said,
how if you start following a guy,
how long do you think he should
wait to Dmu? Because as a guy,
I'll have girls follow me and because
I just do jokes on there. I'm like,
this is Carolina. I don't want to be
like, so you came for the comedy also?
I don't know. Yeah. That's hilarious.
I don't want to fall. I don't want
to bomb her out if she just came to,
she thinks I'm funny, but like,
yes, but what about fucking me?
Can I interest you in
that peanuts? Yes. Um, so,
and of course the answers
were all over the place. Yeah.
Like four days. Five days,
10 minutes. And then I said, but if he's
cute, it doesn't matter. And they wrote,
nope.
Ah, yeah. But if it's aqua
man, just let them slide.
I like that you're referencing aqua man
is like the paradigm of hotness though.
Cause he really is. He's
as good as it gets. He's,
well this is when my wife said she
goes, he's everybody's type. Yeah.
He's a including fish. Yeah.
He's a big giant, handsome,
beautiful man who seems to be
extraordinarily kind. Yeah.
Like he's got like Benny dates and older.
Well, a woman that's older than him,
like he's got he exercises. What does
it say? Furthermore, sex strikes,
I started sleeping less and didn't
read it as pointed by Chicago.
Whist in Kenya, the
Philippines. Liberia. Thanks.
Nobel Prize winner Lima.
Wha How split?
Say That g B o w Wilby keep,
Whoa,
whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa. We,
and in Colombia where women held a
10 day sex strike in 2006 to end gang
fighting.
Wow.
And it is a great idea.
It truly is. Like, if you want
to affect change, just get every,
I was saying to somebody last
night like we all know, like every,
somebody was asking me about uh,
cheating on and I was like, I'm
not a cheater. But I was like,
every guy does what they do.
Most human achievement is because
they men wanted to get like,
yeah,
like buildings,
electricity.
If you think that scab problem in unions,
just trust me.
If you got a fucking sex drive them hoes,
them hoes going to come down. I
was also, what am I going to you?
I have no leverage.
This is my main leverage.
Like, um, but, but yeah,
like it's a, it's a great bargaining
tool. Oh yeah. I mean it's the,
it is the bargaining.
I mean that's,
in some ways that's most
of them negotiation of a
relationship is like where
girls get like women don't control.
It's like they may not
control it explicitly,
but I know if I do something that's
going to get you in a bad mood,
you're not going to fuck me.
And legalized prostitution is one of the,
one of the best ways to
combat any kind of sex strike.
And that is one reason why women fucking
hate the idea of legalized prostitution.
They don't ever want that
to not be negotiable.
They don't ever want you to be able
to go, oh, I'm an asshole. Yeah,
I'm going for a drive.
And you go right down to the store when
you go to the sex store and you pay for
a 10 and she's built like Jessica Rabbit
and you bang and you have a time of
your life and then you go home and your
girlfriend's got a little bit of a gut,
their ass a little saggy and you're like,
I just know.
I mean you can't tell me what to do
anymore. I spent 80 bucks. I just,
I said it wasn't that much. Yeah.
If sex was legal v financially,
if it was transactions,
it is legal in a lot of countries
are not a lot of countries,
but a few cuts of view. Yeah, enough.
But if it was legal in this country,
how much do you think it would shift
perceptions? And the way what people,
I think it would,
I don't know,
cause I was just in Singapore and
apparently it's legal there by the way.
I went to like there's a, I was
in Singapore, did some shows.
Excellent.
And uh,
and there was a place called,
uh,
it's orchard road and it's a mall during
the day and at night it becomes a mall
for prostitutes. They have
a prostitute mall. Yes.
It's dirt road. And the awful saying
four it is four floors of horrors,
which I did.
I hate you. I hate the word war.
Um, I don't know. It just bugs me.
I had something about, it's like you wore,
it just feels like dice or the cooker.
Pr. I Dunno. I like hooker
is a term of endearment.
Call. No, not like mouth shut
your mouth hooker. Like oh yeah,
like a girlfriend who's just joking around
about something. They shut your mouth.
Hooker and that everybody
will laugh. Yeah. Uh,
so, but it, I, so the, the,
the local guys, we're going
there and I was like, well yeah,
I'm going to go also because
I want to see this place.
Cause I've read about it and there was
a restaurant there that they ate in,
which is a whole other issue, but it's
literally like a mall, like a Shitty Mall.
Like not like a, you know, Glendale
Gallery that where it's like, like a law.
It's just one of those like square
ones where it's like four floors.
There's escalator in the middle and
then there's just basically like,
and there's just wimp, prostitutes,
hookers as you call them,
uh,
out in the
walkway. Jamie's got a visual for us
trying to find something, but I found a,
a TripAdvisor review of
Ortho. Nice. Yeah. Wow.
Don't go here at nighttime unless
you want to be shocked a little.
The wholest place turns into a countless,
into countless brothel bars.
I feel like I needed to scrub myself after
our visit. I, I don't diss. Like I, I was
there about three minutes and I was like,
all right.
Cause the thing is there's a difference
between legally legalize prostitution
and anyone wanting to be a prostitute.
They don't want to be,
I mean they are right. I don't think
they're being forced or coerced,
but is coercing
them.
What did you doing it?
What did you think about the
Robert Kraft situation here?
Here's what bothered me about that. Two
things bothered me about that one, they,
they accused him of being a
part of sex trafficking. Right.
But it turns out that wasn't true.
They weren't,
they were just regular girls who wanted
a jerk guys off for money. Right.
It wasn't, there was no one there
on it, I think is a big word.
Would willingly did it
voluntarily, whatever. Um,
and they were threatening to release
the film footage of him. Like,
so what do you do?
And just trying to shame him into
submission and the fact that this guy,
even though he's a billionaire, he can't
stop that from happening. I kept crazy.
Well the funny thing is the fact that
he's a billionaire and still has to go to
them to the fucking drive through.
It's like,
boy, I wished there was a better system.
It shouldn't be a better system. Yeah.
I mean I think it's going to be robots.
I think sex robots are going to be like
blur the morality line. I was at, uh,
this is,
uh,
similar thing about like, there's no, uh,
a release and relief anywhere.
I was at a party recently and
DiCaprio was there and there were,
and there were a bunch. It was
just like a huge, crazy party,
like crazy holiday party, like
the kind. I never go to them.
And it's just like Eddie just
everyone's there and, uh,
Dicaprio's girl wanted to
leave and he goes, well, uh,
the girls are tired.
So I got to leave the greatest party ever.
Like he had to leave, like even did
Leonardo Dicaprio, the king of kings.
The girls are tired. God got to go.
They'd been at the Party for, ah,
I don't know, hour and a
half or something, but there
was like a dinner before,
but it was, it was just a funny
thing, like, oh, okay. So there's no,
it doesn't matter who I am. You still,
when they're done, yeah, when they're,
when they're done, you're going to
go so times. But having said that,
we still all do it for some invisible,
uh,
Shangrila.
I bet she would have stayed at the party
for aqua man. You know what I mean? Yeah.
Aqua man was the man document.
Like, it's fine, let's stay. Yeah.
My feet take off my shoes.
Uh, yeah, the, uh, but yeah,
there's still, he's still kind of,
I mean,
we're still doing it for some primal,
like all the achievements and
all that shit. It's still some,
yeah. Well, you want to be
respected, loved, and liked,
and you want people to desire you.
Yeah. That's part of it. Right.
Even if you're not gonna
take them up on it. Right.
Like I told an anecdote on, on,
uh, how neofill this week, um,
about the best compliment I ever got.
I was doing a show in Vegas with two
buddies of mine who shall remain nameless.
We get on the elevator at the end,
woman gets on and goes,
can I just say I'm married, but
I would fuck all you guys, whoa.
And we, and it was
great, but like, Oh, you
get, we feel accomplished. We
did a great job. At the show,
you're attracted us having to be married
and that's so nothing's ever gonna
happen. But thank you for expressing
your attraction. US A one.
If she was saying, even though I'm
married now, she was saying it like,
just so you know, if I weren't married
by, wasn't married yet, fuck and not,
and she didn't mean at the same time
either. She was a little drunk, she was,
but even tipsy, she had some ridiculous,
that's a very nice thing to say.
Like that's kind of what you want to from
everyone. For a guy. Yeah. Like, Hey,
I would fuck you girls don't want to hear
that. They're like, yeah, thanks. Yeah,
no kidding. Yeah. Everyone
wants to come on to, yeah. Hey,
how do you like doing a
podcast with Bianca? I love,
don't be on, she's hilarious.
She's funny.
She's smart,
smart and she's a pain in
the ass in terms of like, ah,
she is very like,
no,
like she has her own logic.
She has her own belief system
and we just argue it out. Uh,
she's more in like,
and she's also like 10 different races.
She's like, so she's pulling from
a, like her father's Middle Eastern.
She grew up in Oakland.
Like she's got a lot of different,
like it's got Panamanian
and she's got a Panamanian,
she speaks German I think like for real.
Like she's so she's just
like from all over. And uh,
she's a fun,
she's fun and funny and she's funny too.
She's fun to be funny around.
Is she on how Neil feel? Yeah,
she's on hunting field. That's the name
of the, so how, how often you guys do it?
Once a week. Oh, that's cool. Yeah.
What do you do it? Do it in my,
literally in my bedroom. Oh, nice.
Yeah. Beautiful. Cause it's, it's not,
that's the only space we have. That's
cool. But it's like, you know, it works.
How many have you done so far for? Okay,
cool. Nice. The beginning of a podcast.
It's nice. You can see what it becomes.
Low expectations. You'd be like, yeah,
we're still starting out.
Yeah. Uh, I like it either.
Have you done any at the store?
No,
I literally haven't done any,
I don't think maybe I did one in the
basement once. It's a nice little spot,
man that it is. Yeah, it's cool. It is
kind of a cocoon. Yeah, it is. It's,
it's the way they have it set up
down there. It's pretty bad ass.
And the fact that like, wow, we're doing
a podcast at the comedy store. It feels,
it feels kind of historical because that
is the thing that brought that place
back.
Yeah.
Podcast brought that place back from the
brink and made it the thriving center
of comedy.
I think you can all agree that is the
center of comedy in the known you hundred
percent. 100% yeah. And that podcast,
even like Robbie from Netflix is like,
podcasts are like the
indicator of streams.
Like you know, it's, it's pretty
direct. Yeah. The correlation,
and I don't know what Tom would be more
popular from Netflix or the podcast.
They're both pretty fucking like one on
one aide in terms of he's murder in it
right now.
It is.
Podcast has fans like whenever
they do these Garth Brooke things.
Oh my God, Garth Brooks is haunted.
He doesn't know what to do.
He's so trapped by your mom's house fans.
Yeah.
They just won't stop with the means
and the deep fakes with Tom's face of a
Garth Brooks body fight.
DM The guy. Yeah. And uh,
cause I was like, is it hard because
it's terrifying. Someone said,
I did it.
Jamie used the software to make one
with me with Trump's head was easy.
Yes. Fuck very easy. Someone,
I was talking to somebody about it and
they said it bums me out in the way.
Death used to bum me out
when I was a little kid.
Wow. Wow. Oh, I know what he means.
It's like unfathomable. Like,
oh, this is not good shot man.
Chow. Check this out.
God competition for us,
for the US. Look at this. Are you
checking in about which vice president?
Former vice president Biden. The
current vice president is my shorthand.
He actually looks like Joey. Do
you guys do that? Looks like me.
If I was fat and I had a crazy
haircut that looks, that's me.
Everyone's competition. I view
everybody's clarity. That's so good.
How long did it take for real?
Um, it's about the, I was teaching
myself how to do it really. Right.
So like this version took,
I let it run overnight because there's a
little bit of what the machine learning
kind of thing I was doing. The longer you
let that run, the better it is as well.
I've been learning. So this was just my
test of like eight hours, maybe six hours,
have multiples going at one once I made
this year, months or in the hopper.
The crazy thing is porn. They're
doing that with gals that taken like,
you know that you've, you used the
word Gallop's 12, that word. I love it.
This is a good time to bring this up cause
I just saw something today literally.
And it has to do with this, and I don't
know if this is real, but this sounds,
it sounds scary and this is where someone
is taking this technology into a weird
place. Uh, a lady like as a Facebook
post, it's why I don't believe it,
but she said she was with her son
and while she was out of her house,
her husband was called saying that her
son was kidnapped and that he heard his
son's voice saying like, Mommy, help me,
help me, help me. And to give them money.
And the dad was freaking out,
didn't know what to do, did,
couldn't get ahold of them and for
finally did after six minutes and she said
they couldn't even convince the dad that
that wasn't real. Like after hearing, no,
I'm fine. We're fine. I'm with them.
But I don't know if this is even real,
how they could do that at this with
the capability now I'm not sure,
but they might be able to.
Oh, for sure they can do it.
Yeah, they can do with your mind.
I mean if they can do it with faces,
they can do with audio.
They did it with two pocket,
that Coachella like five years ago.
That was the way he said Coachella
is exactly how he would've said it.
And they have that,
that Hologram that looks just like him,
but like a little more jacked. Just a
little like it had more of a six pack.
He like you went to crossfit?
Yep. Yeah. And having uh,
yeah, that's, I can, I totally
believe they can do the voice seven
ago for that one. Wow.
Yeah, they're so close now.
Even if you go back and
watch game of Thrones,
like season one and with the wolf's
look like they look like shit. Really?
Yeah they were. There's Shitty
CGI wolves. A little clunky,
but now they look amazing. Now it looks
like a real fucking wolf. What is this?
That's Tupac. Look, look out. Jackie is,
do you have any idea how many sit ups you
have to do to have a stomach like that?
You gotta be on that Wiz Khalifa
tense also as routine. It's also,
you got to not eat any starts,
right? I mean any sugar,
you can't be fucking around with carbs,
carbs,
that would keep you from being really
shredded. I mean, not all carbs,
but I mean either doing some, a lot
of fasting. You got to do something.
And get your body fat down that low
because it doesn't matter how many sit ups
you do.
Right.
It's not gonna well up to make your ab
muscles bigger and make them more defined.
I can see one of mine, yeah,
you got to lose weight.
The only way he goes on to say that,
no, it's so easy to get fat too.
I'm so amazed at how easy I
can get fat on a vacation.
Like one week I gained 10 pounds.
If I go on a vacation and I just go
drink and eat pasta, 10 pounds in a week.
Well that's like you're running
such a small margin. Yeah,
and just in everyday life
where it's like, yeah, if you,
if you just eat, it's not a man. I mean
it's fairly massive, but it's not like,
what do you think it is? 800 calories
a day. No, that's dry. Made the extra.
I don't know. With me, man, I go
hard when I, when I eat on vacation,
drink, drinking and eating, like just
the drinking. When I'm on vacation,
I might drink four or five drinks a day,
maybe more every day.
Do you drink during the day if you're on
vacation without your [inaudible]? No,
no, no. Not without my kids, but when
my kids are there, I'm hammered. Yeah.
You got to say, yeah, I get no,
but if I'm away on vacation and I'm out,
I might have a drink at the pool
or at the beach, wherever I am.
And then at night if I go to dinner,
I might have two or three,
so I might have four or five
drinks every fucking day.
That's not a normal day for me.
Such as just piling up,
piling up and what are you
drinking? Whatever, whatever.
What do you got got? Yeah.
If I'm on vacation, you know,
I'm trying to get fucked up.
I'm trying to have a good time doing
it. Like it's my job. And Are you,
does your wife get drunk? She'll get
hammered. Not as much as me though.
I get more drunk than her.
That's fun. Yeah. Yeah.
Was you don't know where to go and
you could just walk to wherever you're
supposed to be. Yeah. Yeah. But a
10 pounds later, I'm like, you fat.
Fuck. And I'm grabbing my sides when I
can go grab a fistful of meat. Right.
Where my love handles on.
I'm like Jesus Christ.
Well cause it's so like you fucked up
and you just like have a thing that you
have a handful of regret. Yeah. Take
a week to get everything back in line.
By the way,
that not that long.
I mean that's not a very long time
compared to compared to most people.
Like at your age, fucking people,
People's metabolism. Take them.
People get fat a little bit
and then they're done. Yeah.
But I still do the same shit that I did
when I was 21 like in terms of like the
amount of working out I do. Yeah. I still,
I'm still running the hills and doing
serious kettlebell workouts and martial
arts and all this stuff. At least
five days a week I'm doing something,
muscles shit every day. Are you doing
Tom's? I'll do something every day.
I'll do multiple workouts in a
day because I have a gym at home.
So I'll get up in the morning and lift
and then I'll do yoga and then I'll do
something later. I just, you have to
keep going when you're 50 years old,
like your body requires,
like you can't have too much slack
in that cause when you slack,
if you get out of shape, fuck man, it's
hard to get back in shape. It's hard.
Like your body is trying to die.
Yes.
And not trying to put muscle
on and up your vo two Max.
It's not interested in that.
Interested in dying and the trick that
continuously working out as the kind of
like,
Yup.
I've been cranking the sauna up to 200
degrees because Gabrielle Reece told me
that Laird Hamilton puts his shit on to
2100 twice. That's what she said, right?
To 20, which is you cook meat
at 220 degrees. That's like,
that's fucking hot. And uh,
I was like, there must be
some sort of benefit in that.
So I'm like,
I'm going to ramp my shit up from one
80 to 200 and it made a big difference.
What and what's the difference?
First of all,
it's way harder to do the difference.
Gene one 60 in one, like I was at a um,
a sauna this past weekend at a gym,
like a hotel gym. It was a nice song,
but it was not hot enough. It was like
one 60 ish. And at that point that hot,
you're sweating and it's, it's helping,
you're getting heat shock proteins.
It's good for your body,
reduces inflammation but not nearly
as radically is when you hit 200,
200 is fucking hard to do.
Like you are the, first of all,
the wood in the sauna that
you're sitting on is hot as fuck.
You need your sweat to cool off the
wood because the wood is like a plank.
Like a cedar point through you're cooking
a filet of salmon on the wood gets
like it's how long can you stay in at 20
minutes and those last five minutes are
rough.
And how do you deal with the pain?
Whatever the like you can't, you
don't want to move, right? Yeah.
The last five minutes I'd get
up and I start walking around.
Actually I feel like I have more of a
hard time sitting still in the last five
minutes. So like, uh, yeah, I
would think attractive. Yeah.
I distract myself by stretching and
moving away flip flops or that they would
mouth know you. They'd probably get,
well you know what works though?
Surprisingly airpods those fuckers don't
die out in 200 your phone would be dead
as fuck, but airpods keep going. So if I
put my phone just outside the door, yeah,
but airpods on,
I could listen to music or at least
think they're hot to the touch. Yeah,
they're hot. I feel them. But
they're not breaking down.
They don't do the hang in there at 200
degrees. Good for you or probably, yeah,
they're good. And you feel
it markedly different. Yeah.
You feel good when you
get out of there man.
Like all your little aches and
pains feel like to get a big bump,
like a big reduction in the
aches and pains and that's,
and most your aches and pains, their
age and working out. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just inflammation in Jay.
What age would you be pissed at?
Be pissed.
If you died at 60 would you be
pissed? Do you know what? Nah.
You know what I mean by pests?
Like fucking fuck you.
I fucking did all the right
shit. Yeah. I don't know man.
You know I just heard John Singleton.
He died at 51 Luke Perry
died at 51 or 52 stroke.
Both those guys. That's like
fucking, that's me. That's this age.
Destroy of Stevenson. Even my,
I mean he was not in good shape,
but like he wasn't old. No,
no. He strokes and yeah,
that one's like, oh, was
Keith when he had his stroke?
50 Ah, fuck. Fuck. Yeah.
Like at what point would you be like,
feel ripped off? Probably right now.
So 60 you would be like the shit out
of this body though. It's amazing.
This thing works as good as it does.
You know,
if I think about my body's
like a car that I've been to,
you still feel like you're
beating the shit out of it,
or did you feel like the Jujitsu stuff
was beating the shit out of it? Well,
I still do that though, but I, I
went running in the hills yesterday.
Hard fucking work out
yesterday. How far? Two miles.
But it's straight up or
steep. Yeah, it's like one,
one stretches more than a 200 yards
straight up and it's fucking hard.
It's a hard sprint. I, the dog runs ahead
and I'm trying to keep up with them.
Yeah,
but you get to the top of these really
steep hills when your legs are on fire,
your lungs are killing you. But man,
it makes a difference. But it's also,
are you beating the shit out of your body
or are you just doing it? I'm strength,
right? I'm doing it right, but I am, I am
putting a lot of pressure on the joints.
I'm putting a lot of pressure on
the muscles and it's not simple.
It's not like doing yoga every day.
I'm doing some pretty heavy duty stuff,
but I feel like,
um,
if you do it smart and you warm up a
lot and you stretch and I've been pretty
diligent about recovery
sauna in the big way,
but also a beginning,
a trigger point muscles release therapy
like which is like really hardcore
brutal massage that you
literally want to cry. Like,
like this kind of elbows estimate each
fucking puts her elbow on the back of my
neck and you're like, yeah, but it's,
but it makes a big difference
man. All that stuff, cry
out therapy, all that stuff.
Everything's got a little place.
Yeah. Helps. But the moment,
the main thing is consistency. Like
you can't, you can't take months off,
you can't, you can't take weeks off.
You can't just eat less. You'll, you'll,
it'll slip away. Your body
wants to do what it's been
doing. Yup. Like your spirit,
whatever.
Like whether it's like,
you know whenever the law is that body
in motion stays in motion but it just
does. It's Gunna like sugar, same
thing, eat sugar and you're like,
we've got to get more sugar. Don't eat
it. Four days later you're like, man,
God could feel like
variety is really critical to look.
I'll make sure that I get at least one
or two days a yoga and at least one or
two days of running at least one or two
days of lifting least one or two days a
martial arts,
like do a bunch of different shit,
mix it all up together because if
I don't mix it all up together,
then it's like to just too much
repetitive stress possibility.
Like if I'm just running every day,
I don't, I'm not, I don't
think that's wise. And you you,
why don't you do interval training with
running? I do sometimes, yeah, I do.
I do a bunch of different shit.
I mean sometimes I just do hill sprints
and then I slowly go down the hill.
I'll wait till my heart rate gets below
one 40 and then sprint back up the hill
again. You know, I mix it up,
but the key is consistency.
No matter what you're doing,
whether it's yoga or running, you got
to do something almost every day. Yeah.
I don't do some everyday,
but I'd try to do like I got a treadmill
and I now have a bowflex and practicing
the proud owner of above.
You're the last guy to buy one.
I know bout to go out of business,
but they go,
we just got to fucking a
wonderful from 1988 bro. Yeah. My,
my ex girlfriend's roommate had a bowflex.
I remember using this going,
why in the fuck did you get out of this
big actually and it gets like, it's uh,
takes up a lot of space. Got
a boat. I didn't even put,
yeah, you're right though,
bro. Come on. They don't that
only that's when it, yeah,
it does have like a wing. It
is a wing bird. Does it work?
Yeah, I, yes. You got a good workout.
I got, I'm getting my gains, Bro.
I still have like dumbbells and you
know, other shin bands. I tell people,
well, if you really want to work out
at home, all you need is a chin up bar.
Everything else you could do on the
ground, you can do body weight exercises,
you can do
plenty of. I've got to say, I don't
even think you need a chin up bar.
I mean again,
you know 10 times more than I know,
but I'm saying like what are you getting
from a chin up bar that you can't get
from a push up or a dip or
pull ups you're getting,
but I'm saying it's all done right.
You're getting your back,
you're getting your back.
You're not getting your back much.
You're getting a little bit.
If you do Hindu pushups, we swooped
down and elevate and then come back up.
You're getting a little bit of your back,
but you're really getting your back.
If you're hanging onto a chin up bar
and you using your whole body weight,
that's what you want. That that is, that
is an amazing works. My backout very much.
No. Am I fucking myself? Yeah, for sure.
You have the strength in that bitch to
keep the stability in your spinal column.
You want meat, you want that to be
armored, you know, that's very big.
I have several machines out there that
are just designed to keep my back strong
and you just think it's good.
It's best practice.
Yeah, I do that almost as much
as any other kind of exercise.
I do a reverse hyper. I do a whole series,
the reverse hyper machine. Then the,
the glutes, the glute machine
where you you, you know, no,
I cannot believe how hard glutes.
Like it's the hardest.
That's the one after it. I'm like
wow, I'm gonna fucking throw up.
It's the fucking wars hard and you have
to even like I was talking to a trainer
and she was like, well you need
to like activate your glutes.
And in part of me is like, I don't
even know what you're talking about.
And then the more I research,
it's like our glutes are
dead as like normal people.
We don't use our glutes and
they are literally atrophied.
That's why women's get
get so disgusted by guys.
Flat ass don't like this mother
fucker doesn't even activate as no,
but do you want if he's
gonna run ton of Shit. Yeah.
You have to do a ton of shit just
to, and she's like, you would take,
it would take you a couple of months to
even just get them activated and I was
like,
I don't know what you're talking.
I just thought it was some trainer shit
and it's you have to like turn them on.
Yeah. Like you have to like
do like I do a ton of shit.
I don't even know if I'm doing it
right. They I think iron up. Yeah,
they got together. You got to get a train.
I should get a train and come home, man.
Yeah. You got cash. Yeah. Get yourself
a training and Brennan. Yeah, I shit.
Plus it's good because you have to make,
is this your bowflex? No, I went the news.
That's the mirror.
Look,
if you think I didn't almost by this
you're out of your mind. Magnets.
It's a snapmirror one waiting.
Wait something or other.
I've been seeing this online recently.
I just curious if you've
ever heard of it or no.
If it works well it's got two chords.
How much a resistance,
the resistance is all internally had done
just by magnet pressure that you saw.
What's the maximum amount of stoke?
Cause I don't know if you know this
but I'm jacked. No. Yeah, I heard
how much? 148 pounds in the middle. I
think you'd probably 200 plus pounds.
I think it's, I think one 40 it'll
take care of most people. Yeah.
And if you just doing cables, so 148
on each side, is that what it is?
I don't know.
Literally I just,
it's new and I was just curious if you
had seen anything that looks bad ass.
So the mirror is showing you your forms,
forms versus video versus like
are you doing it correctly
and they tell you what to do and it
goes up and down. It fits on the wall.
Is that a gimmick? That's what I wonder.
Is there any reviews that it's way it's,
it's like brand new. I don't even know
if the reviews are all pretty strong.
This is the, like, as you're saying,
it all comes down to are you going to
do it? Yeah. If you do it every day,
it's fucking great. Right. You just,
most people won't do it every day. Yep.
They just,
because it's got to write it down.
Just like every day I brush my
teeth. Yeah. So do that too,
but takes longer. I meditate twice a day.
It's fucking twice a day. Really. 20, 28.
Wow. Interesting. Yeah.
So how does that work?
Like what do you do a sit down,
set the timer for 20 and a closed
my eyes and repeat the mantra.
And what is your mantra? Sucker
car. Sorry. Oh, sorry. I got
um, uh, and it,
I think it works.
I think I need less sleep as a
result really since I've started,
I started like a year and a half ago and
I needed significantly less sleep from
before and I don't know, again, because
it's impossible to know why, you know,
what's doing what, but what other benefits
in terms of like clarity and stuff.
I don't, again, I don't know. I think
they're good, but I, I can't say like,
well I was writing 4.3 jokes a month
before and now I read 4.8 like I don't,
there's no direct correlation.
I am happy with my output but like,
hmm. Isn't that funny? Yeah.
That like to an average person they'd
be like, wait, wait, wait four point.
You're joking, right? No, no. If
I get four great jokes a month,
that's an amazing month.
Yeah.
Well it's like that.
I was going to bring it up when you were
talking about deer hunting. Yeah. Right.
It's like, yeah. If you it,
you see the special thought
of it all at once. Yeah.
I'm the special,
you had a great line about
writing and that like,
like writing in a notebook or on your
phone that it's like a net to catch ideas.
Yeah.
That really is like thought about that
was like that is a great way to put it.
Yeah. Like here put throw this in
the, put it on the thing and like,
and then you can look back.
You ever have an idea,
write it down and then three days later
looking at like that's fucking fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's funny.
Well that's why you got to throw
a lot of shit against the wall.
I have pages and pages of stuff that I
review like late night rambles that I
labeled them late night rambles
cause I write a lot of times at,
at night after the store. So I by
yourself? Yeah. Yeah. Everyone's asleep.
I'm high and just sit in
front of the computer.
And is it like you have
a germ from the day?
I have sometimes some,
but I have one hour they have to write.
So I'm one hour in front of that computer
and like give myself that one hour and
then after that I can watch youtube
videos or whatever you flicks, whatever.
But I have to get that
one hour in and man,
there's been many times where I'm sitting
there staring at that fucking computer
for 20 minutes and then, and then sh
I got an idea, I'm like oh my God,
there's something. And then the
next day I'd do that onstage. Boom.
It gets a laugh like fuck yeah.
That reward for the tediousness
to is just getting through the,
the sitting in front,
staring at the blank screen,
staring at some fucking
weird notes. You're not even
sure if they mean anything.
Trying to find some old shit where
there's just a spark of light,
an amber blow on it,
turn into a fire.
Or like I had a joke that I try
that I was trying and I was like,
I know it's good. I just have
to come up with the right thing.
Yeah.
And then I try to couple,
the first couple times you fuck it up,
you don't say it right.
It's just so it is the TD and the mild
embarrassment of just like trying and
failing. But uh, but having an idea,
writing it down,
doing it on stage is the,
to me the most rewarding
thing I can think of.
It's one of the most rewarding things
in all of life. Yeah. I mean honestly,
and I don't say that light. I just mean
like living a life. That is the thing. And
it's not, that's the one that's not
really about, women are not about that.
It's more like spiritual.
It's like about like, uh,
yeah. And, and like you,
it goes through the,
your your filter and you're like,
no one ever thought of that. Right. Know
what fucking ever thought of that. Right,
right, right. That's fucking
crazy. Those are the best ones.
So like how did I catch you? Like
how, what that cue. Thank you.
Earth. How often do you write on stage?
How often do you ad Lib on stage?
Very rarely. I you see I come up with
my sheets. Yup. Yup. And like put,
I have a new joke show every
Tuesday in Santa Monica and then,
so I'll go up and do as much new shit
as I have [inaudible] and mix it in with
my ma. I mean, you know that when
you have a punk then you'll put like,
I can do it,
I can put that part in there.
So he kind of have to do some old jokes
that like fit in the new part. Um, and,
but my, I'm like, I usually
am like if I write for jokes,
one of them will work. Yeah. Like,
and I just like nip. Yeah. Alright.
For jokes.
One of them will have signs and then
sometimes the other ones you're like, man,
I don't know if you're alive or not.
I got to stare at you for a little bit.
I had to try to figure out a
way to bring you to life. Yeah.
Is might be something there.
I'm maybe missing it on the
first pass. Set it aside.
You ever have a premise and
years later you'll figure it out.
Years later I'd decade. Yeah.
Yeah. And be like, Oh fuck.
And you just know how to do it now.
Yeah.
Maybe you have a bit that you did that
taught you about something else or some
other aspect of writing a pit and
you couldn't explain it to any,
you couldn't explain it to someone
who doesn't do it. No. Like you can't,
it's kind of not,
I mean maybe athletes a little bit where
it's like they figured the game out in
a different way,
but it's so private and it's so like a,
and that's the thing I was talking
to somebody about this, like
how many funny people are there in the
world. There's a lot of funny people,
but how many of them are
funny? Standup funny. Yeah.
They could just go on stage and make a
roomful of people laugh. That's a hard,
that's a hard couple hundred.
If you're being generous,
you're going to be really general.
Like how many real legit professional
comedians that you and I respect.
Maybe 200 yeah, man, there's
7 billion people in the world
and like that's the rare and I as much
as comedy is like deified in ways that
are sort of goofy now. It's still
like, no, this is all we do every day.
It's fucking interesting.
It's like Ed,
especially now the way the culture is
like we're the only people speaking freely
in public or at least in an organized
way in this, this format as well.
Podcast and stand up those
the only two things. Yeah.
I mean everything else right now
is compromised it seems like. Yeah.
And then everybody else feels at work.
You can't really talk freely at,
in relationships.
There's like, and it's not like
we're just talking extemporaneously,
like I don't even know where I'm going,
but I'm fucking know what's
going to happen at the end
of this sentence. But, uh,
but that, and that's the thing
that's so riveting about it.
It's like is there no one else is doing
and there's only a few hundred people
that can do it. Well, yeah. It's crazy.
And it's also reverting to like the,
the creation of like these,
these little things that you come up with.
If you keep going,
eventually there'll be a special,
eventually it'll be something
that we actually can record. Yeah.
And there's just like these, this thought,
like, I'm onto something. I've got this,
I'm piecing this little puzzle together.
And not even knowing someone said like,
so what do you, how do you
come up with? And it's like,
I don't even know what
I mean when I start.
And then I write the jokes and I'm
like, oh, I see what I was doing.
Or going through.
Do you sometimes rewrite a bit,
like write a bit and then rewrite
it from a different angle?
Okay.
Uh, I mean there's obviously like threads
of like, like you just do the inverse.
Sometimes I'd take a bit when
it's already done and I say, okay,
let me put that aside. I know
it's done. I know it works.
Let me approach the subject from a
completely different angle now. Yeah.
Let me approach the subject as a hater.
Well,
couldn't you do you end up
probably doing both of them, right?
Like a lot of your feminism shit.
Yeah.
The thing you were closing with felt
like you'd written a half and then we're
like, well, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And now my own robot. Well,
I'm wanting to rebut myself. Yeah. I know.
Also wanted to shit on myself so hard
that by the time I got to shit on the
feminists, like it worked. Yeah. Well,
that's another thing where
it's like if you couch,
you can say anything as long as
she's it with like I'm not a monster,
just know that I'm not a monster of
course, but some of these bitches are,
or some of these, whoever's are
like, I'm not a total piece of shit,
but let's talk about that.
Yeah, that's the, the,
I'm thankful that I just thought of a,
another like frame for, uh, for uh,
like I did the three Mike's
thing. Yeah, no I did for Netflix.
So I thought of that frame as like three
microphones on stage and I just thought
of a nother certain that it's
not like a structural thing,
but it's a way to do a show and,
Huh.
Yeah.
My first thought was fucking thank God.
Meaning you don't want to be
like, you don't want to do it. Uh,
premise he show every time.
Cause I did three mics,
then I did a half hour on Netflix,
New Year's Day,
the communities of the world thing
that deleon Swartz into two. And, uh,
and now I'm like, I would like to
do it kind of not one man show.
We think just not a modeling version,
but like a way to do jokes that are more,
it's like jokes, but also if you can
thread something else in it. It's like,
do you see that there
was a ground site live?
I think it was Halsy who sang a song
and fucking painted at the same,
she painted a painting turning
this off and I was like,
wow, wow. See if you can bring
it up. Cause it's like the song,
I can't play it. We'll get, we'll get to
it was the second song. It's our live.
Yeah. If we play it well
we'll definitely get the boot.
Youtube is brutal with their
copyright shit. Brutal.
I mean, so what's, it's just
very, it's good and bad. Yeah.
But it's very easy for someone
to claim copyright off of just,
you play a clip and next thing you
know your video gets taken down.
He can't stream. So part of me is
like, you know, is it right here?
So she's singing, she's singing and
chanting. And by the way. Great. Logan.
Yeah. Okay. Just got a lot going
on. And she's tearful barefoot.
Oh, I mean, is it amazing? No, but it's
fucking amazing for singing to me. Yeah.
It's better than I can do not singing.
I bet she's quite a character.
I don't, that felt loaded.
That's set up front
load of jail. Um, yeah,
so like I thought of another premise, so
I'm excited about that. That's awesome.
When you think you're gonna
film, if you will, you will.
Not long ago I got a, I have,
I've kind of written out,
but like I'm going to probably
do it like in New York,
like I did three mikes where I did it
like sort of op Broadway and, okay.
So when you do something like that where
you do like a long run and then film at
the end of the run. Yeah, I basically did
three mikes. I did for like two months,
four nights a week. So, uh,
ended it all in New York. Yeah.
Oh cool. And then where did you do? Uh,
some theater like on the lower east
side were perfectly does his, and then,
and uh, it was cool. It's cool to just
like have to do an hour every night.
It's a cool like, oh, I'm going
to do an hour and I'm in a town,
I'm in the same town.
That is cool and I'm doing an hour every
night and you're doing essentially like
a play on that. I liked it
was an emotional, there was a,
it was a like an emotional fucking,
I talk about emotional shit.
This'll be less emotional.
It'll be a less wrenching,
emotionally people saw three Mike's like,
it's fucking pretty gut wrenching.
But uh,
but this'll be less gut wrenching.
But you have a premise that's exciting
to you. Yeah. Which is fucking, you know,
that's like fucking excellent.
And it's also the only thing that like,
it's like, well, you're gonna make
money. I don't know. I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
It's like not even a consideration.
It seems like you're wasting your time
thinking about that because all that
really matters is do you enjoy doing
it? This is the audience. Enjoy it.
All that other stuff comes out of
that, right? Yes. If you enjoy it,
they're probably gonna
enjoy it too. Yeah. And,
and even the thing where people go like,
so what are you doing? And you're like,
you can say you're doing the podcast
or you have UFC stuff like go like,
oh you have to have something that
you're working on. And I'm like,
I feel like I'm doing an
hour comedy special for a
huge stream streaming service
that's going to broadcast
fucking everyone's like, what
are you doing? That's it.
You know, that's how they,
and you're like, this is a,
what I'm doing is fucking,
it doesn't, it's not time
consuming visibly day to day,
but like it's consuming emotional,
like thinking about it.
What's your take on what's going on with
Louie? Like what he's trying to do with,
uh,
stopping people from quoting
his bits and the quoting.
I mean, I think he's just trying to
stop people from leaving a shit. Yeah.
It was his own fault cause
he just didn't have the bag.
He didn't have the Undergrad like he could
have him was like, yeah, it'll be fine.
Yeah. What's the worst
that can happen? Why Louie?
So now he's doing everything.
He's got the yonder bags,
he's doing small clubs and he also has a
sign that he puts up saying that if you
leak any of the material that
they have legal repercussions. Uh,
good. Yeah. I mean why should, why
should, it's a spoiler. It's like,
it's like a fucking, but it's
worse than a spoiler. Yeah.
It is worse than a spoiler because every,
every joke is its own movie,
right? It's got its own prize to
exaggerate about it, but it's like, yeah,
it's a huge, it's a, it's
a, that's a huge problem.
And it's also,
it goes to that 11 year old girl thing
where it's like literally said deaths and
what he did that.
Yeah.
Uh Huh. Yeah. When you have 11 year old
daughters, man, it's like you get it. Oh,
now I see how people are thinking.
I'm like little kids. And what's the,
how would you describe it? Like
sort of like simplistic. Yeah.
Looking for something to
be naughty. Someone to do
something back. What did he do?
What did she do? What
are they doing? Well,
we'll tell you right after the break
and you're like, oh, I can't wait. Yeah.
Uh, but I don't, I mean,
Louise a hilarious dude and,
and I hope I,
I'm interested to see what happens.
I think he's going to come out
with a motherfucker over an hour.
That's what I think. I think he's
going to pee. He's constantly touring.
He's on the road all the time doing this.
I know he's not doing it just for money
cause he's only doing these little tiny
places. It's doing Zane. He's
in Chicago right now or Zane.
He's in Nashville right now.
He's going to come out with a
motherfucker of a special and resubmit his
position.
And I think there's going to be people
that are still mad at him no matter what.
I don't matter.
I don't think that you can please most
of the people that are mad at him,
no meaning and I don't, I just think
it's like they're not reasonable. They,
it's more fun to not forgive
him. Yeah. It's ideal.
It feels better to not forgive him. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Fuck him. Yeah. I get it.
I get their perspective,
but for everybody else,
we're going to get treated to a
monster hour. That's what I think.
I hope when he's all done, I think it's
probably going to be as best hour, hour.
I listened to the, the leaked one. Yeah,
it was good. Yeah, it was good. I mean,
10 months out, man. No, no.
Comedy it off for 10 months and then
he starts doing it again and there's,
you know,
some bits in there that would have
been great if they didn't get leaked.
The thing about what are you going to do?
Cancel my birthday is so fucking funny.
It's in, it's like, yeah, he's
so fucking funny. It's bananas.
Yeah.
Cause my life is over like
you to cancel my birthday.
Ah. So God damn funny. Um,
yeah. Yeah. Like I, you know,
he's an, he's a fucking
hilarious dude. Yeah. That's
the front of the line. I mean,
when it comes to comedy and political
correctness and the pushback,
that's the front of the line
for the pushback is stand up.
Let nightclubs stand up.
The stuff that you and I both do,
we say a bunch of fucked up things that
happen to also be funny and you're doing
it in front of live cry or I'd
set on safety of the night,
they're going to a strip club
and complaining about cellulite.
That's what it feels like. It's
like, what do you, this is,
we say a ton of shit.
Some of it doesn't work.
Somebody doesn't work because it
doesn't cross the, the comedy barrier.
Some it doesn't work cause
it's ideologically fucked up.
But you don't know it until
you say it's like, yeah.
Even the funny many great bits that
you love are fucked up to someone sure.
To someone like,
or you have to figure out a way to make
them more like Chris Rock's bit about
this difference between black people in
the end. Yeah. That bit he said bombed.
Oh yeah. A long time before
we figured out how to go.
Shortly before he did it
on his, on his uh, crazy.
Um, it's great, but he knew,
he's like, God dammit, there's
something in this. Yeah.
Uh,
and,
and also it is fucked up.
It is a fucked up. Like it's fucked
up. You can weaponize that joke. Sure.
A lot of white people did like a lot
of racist white. But like I told you,
I've been saying to that in my car
for years. Um, and that exactly,
but at the same time you can't worry about
that. Like I was talking to uh, some,
I did a thing on the pockets
where I was saying like,
I don't understand the problem with
Jordan Peterson and you and I have talked
about this at the, at the
club like, and, and then,
and people email me and they said,
well,
people use Jordan people,
right wing people use him as an example
of Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah. I'm like,
that's not his problem. Right.
That's, and he promotes,
someone said he promotes an all meat diet.
No he doesn't.
He said he does it,
but he didn't promote it.
He didn't make a
commercial about the shit.
You can't worry about how someone takes,
again,
this goes to a point is how
someone interprets your art.
Use Channy interpretation exact.
And also by the way,
then throw away taxi
driver and uh, and uh, uh,
the [inaudible] book,
the Catcher in the rye cause that's
responsible for killing Lennon.
Shooting Reagan like [inaudible]
just like, okay, well,
so these fucking dummies use
it as their thing. Right.
So now I can enjoy it. Like to
fuck go fuck yourself. Yeah.
There's too many interpretations.
There's too many perspectives.
There's too many people. You just have
to be a reasonable person. Be Nice,
do your shit, do your best.
And you know, look, we worked
together all the time, man.
People are laughing. Yes. People
are having a good time. Like, and,
and it's not, it's also like,
what's your intention? Yeah.
It's not our intention is to create,
right.
Our intention is to come up with funny
thing and like me as a person who enjoys
standup,
I like sitting in the back of the
[inaudible] and watching someone kill I
fucking July. It's the best. I told
somebody that like I'm a gym rat,
but for comedy club, yeah. Yeah.
I've been seeing you for 27 years.
Yeah. Just hanging out, like
me and Chappelle were in
Vegas and some kid was like,
what do you, he was a chef at,
uh, this place yellowtail and,
and he was just saying like, being a chef,
you just fucking have to cook for 12,
10 years, 10, 12 years, just like
itch hard and shitty. I was like,
I've known him for 28 years.
He's been going to clubs for 33 years.
Like,
that's the only thing that Matt,
it just makes sense.
It's fair. It's like it's an
economy that you understand.
If the idea is good enough, the we'll
get this response and there's not,
there's not really politics.
There's not, there's preferences,
but there's not like, you
know, like, oh, uh, have him,
although you've got the fact that you
got banned from the store is hilarious.
That is like from a movie, like we'll
band, we have to ban one of them. Uh,
but, uh, but, and you won in
the end as it were. But, um,
but it is a fair thing and
it is like the only people
as rock says, we're like x
man. Where it's like they,
they're always mad at the x men.
They're always mad at the x man. But
like fucking, he's still like the ECZEMA.
Yeah. You're mad. You're,
you're mad at Louie.
But fuck if he went on stage and you
know, the mother fuckers hilarious. Crazy.
Yes. If he walked on stage, they would
stand up and give him a standing ovation.
Yes. And there's also, it's also the,
it's almost the corporate thing where
it's like, if, if, um, you know,
Chinese slaves are making phones,
did they make this one like this part?
Like,
whereas with Louie,
it's like this one guy is responsible
for all institutional sexism.
It's like, no, he's not. He's
a fucking, he just was a dumb,
he just was dumb.
And he handled,
he was dumb from beginning to end
and he talked about it. He will. Yes.
He was fucked. He just fucked
up and it was stupid. Um,
but he doesn't have to take the
fall, uh, you know, whatever.
Like he is valuable. Yeah. He's a
valuable, these valuable to our culture.
It creates a lot of,
I don't think of standup this way where
it's like you create joint for people.
I'm like,
I never think of it that way.
But he did create a lot of
thought and joy and like, yeah,
he's responsible for a
lot of positive shit.
I mean, that is what
the art form is. Yeah.
You're literally changing a
person's state and that w I mean,
as an audience member, I still
love it. And that was, uh,
that was a struggle for me
early on because I was jealous.
I could see people doing well and I
wasn't doing well. I was like, God,
I wish I was doing that. I wish I wrote
that joke. I wish I was doing that show.
I wish I was. And then I realized like,
oh, this is like totally unproductive.
Like the opposite of productive.
It's negative.
And so it can be activating in terms
of like, if you turn it into bleed,
then work harder. Right? Well, but the
problem is like, I wish I did that.
Like that part of is no good or God, why
is he have to get this? That part of is,
there's no positive to that. But what
is positive? You Watch someone kill go,
God damn, he's funny. I got to go
to work. Yeah, that's good. But the,
the hate part is,
is like spat instinct.
It's not, it's counterproductive.
It's really common.
I think it's then 11 year
old, it's, that's your first.
That's the easy reaction.
I'm like, no, yes, yes. Ah,
the 11 year old man. And then
it's like, okay, but what am I,
what's underneath that? What's
underneath that is like respect. I don't,
and then there's certain people that
it's like, I've never hated Brian Righ.
Right. Do you know what I mean? Like, and
also like, there's so loves him. Yeah.
And he's fucking hilarious
in a way that's just like,
I don't know this fucking dude.
This dude's funny.
He's so funny and so clean.
You could take your grandma to see him
and never worry for a second. A gall,
where's he going with this? Yeah. Grandma
gets said so fuck, I gotta get a drink.
Yeah. He, he's just,
he's one of those rare cats like Gaffigan
that figured out a way to make clean
just as Sebastian too though.
Yeah. Like Sebastian to the,
I always forget he's clean
and eight bar gutsy. He's
now like getting into that area where
he's like clean southern accent.
Like it's a big,
it's like it's a good place to be,
but he's fucking so funny if you're
naturally inclined to do that. Yeah. Yeah.
Like if, yeah. If you're forcing
yourself to it. Um, but uh, yeah,
I think that there's a ton of value in,
in standup. I mean it's, it
seems so obvious, but it's like,
and I think Netflix must,
there must be some metric
of Netflix where they,
at a certain point they're
losing a ton of programming,
meaning all of their shits licensed.
Disney's taken all their shit back in
like a year or two. A lot of like parents,
like all of these places are starting
their own apps, so they're going to lose.
And I think they realize like, oh, a lot
of Netflix is stand up and documentaries.
And I think that must
be in terms of like pry,
they can never monetize it in terms of
like if the Ali Wong special begat this
much money,
but if it costs them 500 grand
to get alley walks for special,
including
production, everything, they made a lot
of money. You know what I mean? Like,
and it's millions of people watched it
and like as well he should because he's
fucking great.
So like they,
it's just a cool, it's just the
coolest thing I can imagine. I agree.
Like being a convenience.
The coolest thing though man.
I mean that's, that's the,
the have the appreciation and respect
for something that you enjoy doing.
That is actually your, your, your,
your, your answer. Occupation. I mean,
it's a beautiful thing.
We're really,
really fortunate and the
gifts that we get like a low,
you know what I mean? Like it's all for,
it's all from comedy. Yeah. Glasses,
shoes, car. Yeah, everything
you're doing. Yeah.
Basically like every single thing
is from just a personality quirk.
Yeah. And like creativity, work,
grinding too. I like grinding.
I really do it when I'm doing three,
four shows a night,
I get a kick out of it and I'm like,
here we go. This is how things get good.
Work a joke out. Oh, the best.
That's how they come alive. Yeah.
I gotta wrap this up then.
Brendan, tell people your podcast.
How do you feel you go to find a friend,
Bianca,
and fucking doing it with her? She,
yeah. Very cool. Yeah, it's great.
We get good chemistry and um, and it's
iTunes everywhere, so go check it out.
It's just me. It's like this. Except it's
like this. Yeah. It's like this. Yes.
Except as a higher pitch voice.
Disagree with not much higher.
And Joe might have pretty, yeah, it's kind
of high. Right. All right. Bye everybody.